Today's all about positivity.
Ladies and gentlemen,
today,
today we're bringing it back to the plus side.
There's been some ripples in the force over the last few days.
We've gone through them and through a strict diet of staying awake all night and
not get enough food,
no system or back.
I'm living off macaroni salad and living off macaroni salad and flashlights that
Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight and enter in
the code name Brogan,
you'll save yourself 15% off the number one sex toys for men.
It's also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com Brian,
we're going to get you some Onnit pills.
I'm going to get you up on it on it.
Uh,
what,
what is on it?
What is that?
It's,
well,
most of it is nootropics,
Alpha brain being the most popular and most controversial.
And my favorite one with nootropics are,
if you're interested in any of this stuff,
I suggest you Google it.
Go Google the word neutral bic and listen to the research pro and con.
And you know,
there's been studies done on various nootropics that have actually helped
people,
uh,
who had Alzheimer's disease.
And there's a bunch of research to suggest that there are nutrients that can
enhance the levels of neuro cameras,
have a neurotransmitter's that your brain makes and enhance the way your brain
functions.
It's very controversial,
but if you're interested in it and you want to try it,
Alpha brain,
the first 30 pills,
there's a hundred percent money back guarantee.
If you,
if you try it and you'll like,
this stuff sucks,
you don't even have to bring the pills back enough to send them back and you
just say,
this is not for me.
If you are into it,
enter in the code name Brogan and you'll save 10% off any and all orders and go
to the website and check out all the different information and uh,
all the different explanations for what each thing is supposed to do in,
and do your research,
Google it and check it all out.
But we're,
we're very concerned with making sure that no one feels ripped off in any way,
shape or form.
That's,
that's primary before even making money.
That's why it's a hundred percent money back guarantee on your first order.
If you try it and you're like,
this is just not my shit,
I take it.
I took it before I ever endorsed any of this stuff.
I took a bill,
Roman oskies neuro one,
if you know about Bill Romanowski had a lot of head injuries,
a lot of concussions,
and one of the ways he dealt with it was concocting this neutral big blend.
And I became fascinated with the nootropics and his stuff.
I still recommend that I still buy it too.
It's good stuff and it's got,
it actually has a bit of,
I believe it has a bit of caffeine in it too,
which I like,
you know,
phone real fucking pick me up.
It's great stuff.
Anyway,
check it out.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and and it,
my friend Brian counts here and the party went.
Now Begin Ladies and gentlemen,
Ladies
[inaudible] experience [inaudible] the opening forever.
Coolest moments of my UFC broadcasting career.
How about Rory Macdonald?
He's in there too.
He's at the beginning.
That kid is ridiculous.
God,
he's scared and was so much bigger than him too.
I'm going to shoot a single leg on you at will and then I'm going to climb you
and I'm going to beat you up.
He's so scary because he's,
first of all,
he's like super duper dedicated and he's one of those kids.
He's only like 22.
You know when you're only like 22,
23 years old,
man,
you can get,
if you get that good,
that young,
you can get away with a lot of shit.
He can't.
He's the one who came up with just pure MMA.
But I also think I'm as good as these athletes are now and everything else
there.
There are some people that have a,
um,
like a real edge,
but it's gotta be because their philosophy and who's teaching them,
you know,
sort of there cops that it's certainly part of that.
But to get a Roy McDonald,
it's so rare.
It's so rare that you get someone who has that kind of focus,
that kind of intensity.
Dude,
how about his,
his,
his a stair and that I've met in the beginning of that creepy dude.
He just goes quiet.
His whole body just goes fucking quiet.
He's like a Predator like the way Elian when it stops really quick to seize.
Yeah,
just shoot.
And I was like,
that dude's so focused.
It's ridiculous.
He's very unusual.
Very unusual kid.
Seems like a really nice guy outside of fighting,
super friendly,
really easygoing and just mauling motherfuckers.
He just does what he wants and Net and 22 you see what at that age,
when you're really young like that,
you can get so good so quick.
And when you're with kids that are really focused and really dedicated at those
early ages,
they make these huge leaps and like six,
eight months,
these giant leaps,
it take a grown man years to,
to hit [inaudible] just really accelerates so quickly.
I think that's like my buddy was right.
He's writing a book on learning and he's the kind of like just one of these guys
went to Harvard and stayed with,
hasn't he speaks literally,
he really does speak seven languages fluently,
like really does.
Wow.
And he has his degree in biomedical engineering and all these one,
is it kind of a genius?
And,
and uh,
I said,
how do you speak all those languages?
He goes,
well,
it's funny because I'm writing a book about learning.
And I said,
well,
what's your philosophy?
He said,
well,
most of the time with learning when you,
when you have to learn something,
you already have a lot of preconceived notions about what you can and can't do.
So you usually come to the equation with this notion that I'm good at this.
I'm not good at that because somebody along the way told you that.
So most of what learning is,
is,
is just getting out of your own way before you can even learn anything.
Because you come to it with your own projection,
your own sort of,
um,
a scaffolding that you put on it.
And,
and so his philosophy is like he just said,
I can speak languages.
I'm gonna get out of my own way.
I'm going to find the system.
So it's like Tim Ferriss says,
if you want to learn Spanish,
do you only have to know really 2.5% of the words?
And you can understand 95% of Spanish,
it'll take you five more years to learn,
uh,
5% of all the Spanish words.
But you'll only learn,
you only understand 98% of spam.
You,
the increment is very small.
So there's,
there's a,
there's a to learning.
It's just like when you want to educate yourself,
there's,
it's,
there's a system to it.
There's a way to do it.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a methodology and actually a pattern and a path to follow.
And most people spend a lot of time,
you know,
wasting,
wasting a lot of time with a lot of periphery stuff.
Mainly dealing with the fact that they're not good at this.
I'm not good at math,
I'm not good at languages.
I'm not good with money.
And what he'll do in this book that this premises is,
those are all a belief systems that somebody else put on you.
You don't,
you,
that's actually not true.
And you can get rid of it.
You can get rid of him if you know how to approach something.
So it's pretty wild.
Um,
so you know,
someone like Rory Macdonald probably started so young that this is a language
and it's the only language has ever known.
So when you teach him something,
he's not in his own way.
He's like,
well,
I'll just,
I'll just incorporate this into my arsenal.
That's a real good point because when we used to get guys who came from other
styles that would want to learn taekwondo,
there's a difference to the style of kicking and a,
a lot of it,
I incorporated how you lifted up your knees and uh,
the,
they had developed a style of kicking where the knee was down and then the foot
was above the knee and it's,
it's a more like leg centric style of kicking.
Whereas the taekwondo style,
the knee is a pie which opens the hips up.
And when the hips open up,
then there's a turn of the whole body and it's got so much more power to it,
but we couldn't teach them how to do it.
They all would,
especially when sparring,
it would just drop their knee and it would be normal stuff and be like,
do you gotta get your knee up?
That's the most important thing.
The knee is everything.
Well,
the knee comes power.
A huge part of learning also is that is exactly what you're saying because like
a lot of times you,
you go to what's comfortable.
Yeah,
go and because,
because practicing actually the way to get good at something,
obviously it's to practice what you're not good at,
what makes you uncomfortable,
but it doesn't have to make you uncomfortable.
What's making you uncomfortable is the notion that you,
you is the things that you've put on it.
So I'm weak.
I'm not good at least.
See a lot of guys that come in and Jujitsu and they only do what?
What?
They're good with it.
They don't spend time on their back or they don't spend time,
whatever.
Why?
Because they're going to look vulnerable.
But you're defining that that process as vulnerable,
you can redefine the process,
you can decide that it's just you getting better cause you're working on where
your soft,
right.
So it's really so much of it is your attitude monitors your talent,
what you come in with and actually more a more specific way of saying it is what
you don't come in with it.
So much of learning is actually not an addition,
a process of addition.
It's processed,
deletion deleting.
Right.
You know,
you're,
I think actually,
you know it's funny as you become an adult and you get better at something,
you know,
certainly for me with stand up,
so much of it is just like letting go of a lot of stuff,
like deleting things in my mind that I don't need to be thinking about.
I should be thinking about something very positive.
So you started learning.
I started drifting off into something I'm worried about.
I just gently bring my mind back to writing about standup.
I bring it back to stand up,
I bring it back.
Right.
And the joke,
I bring
it back to thinking about this TV show I'm trying to do so you can actually get
very disciplined and good at at redirecting your mind.
It's not a,
it's not a PA,
an active process.
You can make it a very passive process.
You know,
a lot of times when you hear people talk about work,
I got to go to work,
I got to do this work.
We put this,
this sort of sacred scaffold.
It's a sacred like fence around work.
I'm playing now,
I'm going to work.
It shouldn't be that way.
You can completely blur that line.
You can completely like just decide,
well,
work is what I do anyway.
I'm just going to gently start thinking about what I want to be and what I want
I want to be doing and how to create something.
You had.
The work issues are very,
it's a very touchy issue for a lot of people because most people,
that's the bane of their existence.
Yeah,
and with us,
it's actually what we love to do.
That's a,
that's a trick pill for a lot of people to swallow.
That's really fucking hard.
A lot of really want to hear that.
That we associate the idea with work at some point in our life with displeasure
with that's right.
Uncomfort with with you don't want to be there.
It's not fun.
It's not what you look forward to.
Well,
well because for I think the ideal when you talk about work,
the ideal is and,
and I think anybody who's in a position where they don't like if you're in a job
you hate or whatever,
the only way to get out of that job is people say,
well I'm going to move and I'm going to do this is actually to come up with
another idea.
You know,
if you can,
if you can try to come up with a better idea,
it'll beat the other idea.
So you might be doing something but,
but the work actually is about imagination.
It's about just sitting there and letting it come to you.
Figuring I just be figuring out what is your process?
What is,
what do you,
what is your private as a different process and listen to music.
Somebody will walk.
What's,
what's the process you have to undertake to feel,
to,
to get yourself into a creative mode where you're coming up with ideas,
whether you're an entrepreneur,
whether you're a writer,
whether you're a painter,
even if you're an athlete.
I mean,
you know Rory Macdonald,
those guys have to constantly think about MMA and I'm noticing is they always
have to reinvent.
They got to keep adding to their arsenal.
They got to keep growing.
And a lot of that's imagination then,
right,
isn't it?
I mean a lot of it imagination,
that's how it's manifesting itself.
Their creativity isn't beating the fuck out of people and it will people that
are as Dan is like you,
you,
you actually have to be creative and fighting.
It's a very creative thing and it when it,
when you get good at it,
it's a lot of it is figuring out how to hit someone in a way where they can hit
you back or where you hit them first,
where they're trying to hit you but you get out of the way and then you count
her and hit them.
And in doing that,
you can pick up like dumb people fight dumb.
They Ma,
they waddle forward first day throw the left and then they throw the ride and
all you have to do is keep your wits about you.
You see the left come and you know the rights coming.
It's just not,
it's not going to be an upper cut either.
It's going to be a big stupid overhand.
Right.
And that is that.
That's the language that they in.
When your creative,
you become very scary.
Like a guy like Jon Jones is very frightening to people because he's very
creative in his attack.
You don't know what he's going to do.
I mean he fights shogun.
Shogun is like the best trackers or if he opens with a flying knee,
cracks him.
The John shoguns never the same.
He fucked them up from the first sec few seconds of the fight when he threw
Rashad Rashad Evans in that flying triangle.
You know,
he's just like,
I have,
I'm doing MMA.
I just want to see if I could do it.
It's old guard for no reason to Colorado was that way.
I remember soccer,
I would show up in in a t shirt that said water or a paint muscles on himself
and he was completely creative.
And I think that's the lesson,
right?
Yeah.
You don't know what he's doing.
But that'll come on some shit.
But see that comes from,
if you,
if you actually look at most people and we all do it,
a lot of people,
especially young people,
as they start becoming aware of the world around them,
what they'll do is they'll look for something very strong to define themselves
as I'm a fighter,
a,
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm a slacker,
I'm a skateboarder,
I'm,
I'm fucking rebel.
I get tattooed.
And when you define yourself along really strong lines,
I think it becomes varied.
And I'm not talking about defining yourself character wise.
I'm talking about the finding yourself just is as,
as as a first thing.
Yeah.
Well I'm a right wing guy.
Exactly.
Feel as what happened or have.
And what happens when you do that is that you,
it's very hard not to take yourself very seriously in that regard.
Right.
And,
and then you don't have room to create because you're that,
that's what I'm talking about.
Those lines are very precious and you don't want to break those lines because
then you don't know where to go.
Then you're in the danger zone.
You know it.
When you define yourself very strongly like that,
it's kind of like a way of um,
uh,
protecting yourself.
But I think someone like,
what's his name?
Um,
at the spider.
uh,
Anderson Silva.
He,
so he comes up dancing.
that's part of his technique.
He's very loose.
He stays loose.
He doesn't take it too seriously.
Kind of raises his hands from Shell.
Someone's calling them out.
You know who Brian is the image down?
Huh?
There's the image down on Ustream image.
Yeah.
It's a big black screen.
It's lately use stream's been weird with browsers.
Like lot of people are saying that the sound doesn't work and stuff and it's
just,
I think a chrome mostly,
but it's amusing.
A safari.
What do you use?
These rooms are refreshed it,
it came back.
You,
by the way,
people watching this are probably wondering why I'm dressed like a professional
athlete because I look like a professional soccer player.
I looked like a European soccer player.
Maybe rugby,
maybe rugby.
Dude,
I've got a thick neck.
You can't tell right now because I'm wearing a collar.
But I have a beautiful body under this.
What was your,
what was your showtime special called?
It's called man class.
Madam clown.
Man Class.
Okay.
It's called man class and it was ridiculous.
Uh,
I need to come up with a name for mine.
I've had very good feedback.
Thank you.
My main class,
um,
because I was,
I was like,
I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm talking about what it is to be a man in 2012.
And I was like,
I'm just going to fucking teach a math class right now.
And uh,
I'm,
I'm obsessed with this problem of masculinity in a fucking world that's so
technological.
Like we're still producing testosterone and we're aggressive and we have
nothing.
All we had to do it,
all we can do is simulate.
I go to the gym,
I'm working though.
I'm doing fucking kettlebells.
Why the fuck do I need to fuck?
You know,
the to swing a kettle bell for,
but I got to keep my traps up to a buck and I'm learning how to box my buddy
Karen Gallagher.
I'm like in my,
in my backyard.
He's,
please bring me through all this stuff like Free Ryan.
Here's,
here's the deal.
Somewhere along the line we got made to feel guilty for being manly,
for being men grove,
liking men shit for liking manly things.
We got somehow or another we became guilty of that.
I think women,
you got to let chicks be chicks.
You got to let them wear their crazy heels and they're,
they're nutty short skirts and you know the,
the,
the heels that you don't understand the dresses,
that don't mean anything to you.
But to them it's like super important.
That's all girly shit and that's when you're into,
that's fine.
But if you're in the manly shit,
if you're in like man style things,
you're looked down upon like,
oh,
come on.
That's what makes me so angry.
That's what makes me so angry because listen,
up until very fucking recently we've had to fight and hunt for our own food.
You know how much you not think about what kind of,
what kind of aggression and tasted get on a horse or run to the forest and spear
a wild animal and then cut its throat with a stone knife or just a regular
night.
You smelled that animal.
Yes,
I use a stone knife.
Personally,
I don't want to brag but I,
I like to hunt with stone tools.
I watched a whole special,
a believer who was on the history channel where guys made bows and arrows the
traditional way like and,
and when hunting with it,
I just pitched a show to discovery about,
I'm with my Buddy Sam Sheridan,
who you know,
and,
and we're going to go and find all the masculine pockets in a demasculated
America.
So we're basically going to find guys in Hawaii who fund whole hunt,
wild boar using traditional Hawaiian,
like the ancient hunting tools like stone spears and whatever the fuck it is.
And we're going to go find those groups.
And just kind of like showcase these groups and kind of join him and could be a
funny fucking show.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
that'd be amazing.
There's a huge need for men.
You know,
women have an instinct to preen right?
They just have an instinct to print in the like birds do you see them?
You know,
you need,
they've got 15 different lip glosses and different creams and rubbing their
hair,
whatever the fuck it is.
Hundreds trope guys.
You know my joke about guys,
the criteria for guides,
the way they dress is they don't want to look like a pussy and they got to be
comfortable.
That's all it is.
I fucking only loose hanging shit.
Okay.
And,
and um,
I even think that,
you know,
I,
it's,
I can't prove this,
but whenever you see a dude like,
like I always make this joke,
but it's true.
You if you're in Boston or parts of Long Island in New York and you show up in a
cool,
you're a guy and you show up in like a really sexy like hipster outfit and you
got like fucking awesome bangles and you're,
you got a nose ring,
you can get beat up by just dude just of the way you fucking look.
They're like,
I like that guy.
How come he's got a fucking nose ring and he's got bangles?
I'm gonna Punch him in the face.
And I think it might be because those,
that guy's not part of our hunting party cause all that fucking jewelry makes a
lot of noise and the fucking animals here him and they smell his fucking Cologne
and they can,
they can smell that too.
So I'm going fucking hungry so you're not my hunting party so I'm going to beat
you up because you represent hunger to me.
I really think that's part of like what we have that instinct it.
That's a funny way of thinking about it.
I always thought it was just,
you know,
want some douche coming around and dress like,
stealing my women like a pirate.
You know,
you don't want some dude who thinks he's Johnny Depp in pirates of the Caribbean
is walking down your street,
wear Mascara,
talking to girls.
Like what are you doing dude?
I fucking,
I live in Venice.
Okay.
I see dudes with hoop earrings and they're straight.
If you're gay it's fine.
You got away with a lot.
But I see guys just show up with,
like,
I saw a guy with a leather like,
like a leather.
When you say hoop earrings,
how big are these hoops?
They weren't very big.
Very fucking bank.
Okay.
Is that the dude thing do to try to wear like
Diana Ross and the seventies theories?
He had Umaine have thick hair that he tied with this awesome.
Like Bo,
part of it was,
I was just jealous of the fact that he has great hair,
but you know,
he had,
he looked like a fucking pirate.
He had,
you know,
he had his jeans rolled up just so with these,
oh,
I was like,
where can I vote for you,
dude?
Did you have both ears,
pierce?
No,
just the left just about had to piercings.
I had a lower one and then a diamond by lower when he means his Dick Ladies and
gentlemen,
and then I tried to rock to two hoops at the same time,
but I'll even,
I was like,
what is too tough?
And then I tried to rock to studs at the same time.
Then I'm like,
oh,
it's so stupid.
So that I went to one tiny little hoop earring,
I think like somewhere around news,
radio and then Jujitsu,
just constantly taking it out to to role.
I just said,
this is stupid.
You get to staff.
By the way,
have you tried to put one in recently?
I just tried it the other day and it went right in.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Rock.
Kind of hearing your head.
Both pierce though.
Did you think about doing it?
I did it for a day.
I like,
I just as a joke,
my dad was an Irish,
like kind of marine,
like just kind of a rough due to grow up like on a farm.
And the dude I shut up.
Like if I shut up with a hat or like just something cool at dinner,
he just do shit like this.
He was just as big fucking dude and he'd go,
why are you wearing that hat?
And that's how I would have asked me.
Or one time I,
I had a goatee,
I grew a mustache,
a little awesome soul patch on my chin and I was going to Italy and I spent way
too much on clothes cause I was going to be Italian and my father,
I was like,
I was like 28 my father looks at me and he goes like this.
He goes,
what's going on with your face?
And I go,
oh no.
I just thought I'd go out mustache and a little goatee,
you know,
and he,
and he goes,
yeah,
you get,
you get to,
you're going to see how long have you been aware of that?
For around me kind of go,
you don't like it?
He goes,
it's not
you thought you,
there is something weird about when you go really try hard to change your image,
but one of those things where
it's really kind of dependent upon like how transparent are your intentions or
are you just one of those dudes that really can just pull that shit off like
Joey Diaz could.
He could pull off anything you want.
If he really believed in it was a hundred percent behind it.
Joey Diaz could start wearing jumpsuits them back jumpsuits and fanny packs.
If he had a backpack everywhere of Joey Diaz just all of a sudden started
wearing like running suits with a backpack,
we would go,
all right.
I guess that's how he's doing it.
I,
I've never been able to,
that's the other reason is I just,
I don't know how to do it.
Like I'm really bad with putting quality together.
Like I don't have any creativity,
so like I was,
when I shot my special,
I went to see this stylist and the dude shows up and he's like,
he's got me in a hat.
I had a hat,
a fucking necklace,
and a blazer.
And by the way,
I looked outstanding walking out stay.
I was like,
I'm the best looking guy in America.
this is great.
Problem is,
I don't know how to wear a hat or jewelry or a fucking blazer.
It's too hot.
It feels too constrictive and I'm doing it for the wrong reasons.
I just,
I'm doing it because I,
I'd be very aware of the fact that I looked awesome or at least I'd act that way
and I just can't do it.
That's worked well.
Being a comedian too,
you can only be so ridiculous.
I know.
You know,
you can only try.
So like w who wants to watch a comedian go on stage dressed like he's trying to
get laid,
who wants to watch a comedian with like skin tight shirts with the button up?
What are those things called?
The that button,
the thermals or whatever.
But you know that style,
there's a style to,
it can't be too sexy and tie and pants that are already have rips in them.
Like
Russell Grant,
you can do that,
but I don't really,
again,
I'm not as good looking as Russell brand.
I saw that the other day where the guy had like his hair done up like nine oh
two window like the slick,
like,
like poof and the top front.
And he had like the white shirt that kind of was cut too low and then he like a
little shell necklace thing going on there and he was doing jokes about how
everyone,
you know,
confuses me with like Dillon from nine oh 200 like he actually brought up the
way he looked at it as an open Mike night.
No,
this was a show at a
Doug Davidoff tells real joke what's based on a true story where a guy got out
of a BMW when he first got to La and tough grew up in a junk yard and jersey,
you know,
so the guy,
the guy fucking gets out of it.
BMW,
the squaring kind of a Cape like a,
like a cape,
like kind of a like a long,
it's not even a duster.
It's a Cape and a guy goes,
hey,
you know what time it is and thought it was like,
you're just going to ask me what time it is.
Like you're not wearing a fucking cape.
It's time to take the fucking Cape off.
Fuck you doing.
I'll punch you in the face right now and I don't even know you.
It's so,
so hilarious,
you know.
Have you seen that thing that Robert Kelly where's he talks about it at once in
a while and opiate Anthony and it's like,
it's like,
um,
I can't remember the name of it,
but it's a like a fanny pack that instead of having it around your crotch,
it's like this thing that goes from like the left side to the right side.
Like a seat
only Robert Kelly could get away with that.
I love Robert Robert.
Yeah.
Robert could get away with it though.
It's a man purse.
You know,
as you get older and you're not trying to get laid,
you start saying things like,
what the fuck?
Why don't I just have a purse?
He started saying shit like sometimes I need,
I have cargo shorts on.
You know why?
Because I have a lot of shit.
I got my keys,
I got some money,
I got some gum.
The other,
I was just,
the other day I was in my car singing at the top of my lungs and these girls
pulled up and usually I would have been like,
ah,
I'll sing and I'm a fucking idiot.
I was like
singing as loud as I call it is a song.
You're saying.
I was singing a new song by Springsteen called death to our hometown.
Whoa.
You just went deep.
I shared dead guys.
You told me you had some sort of religious experience at a Springsteen show I
had and I'm not joking.
I went and saw him.
He's 62.
I've seen Springsteen,
let's call it,
because I'm on the podcast and I want to exaggerate 30 times.
It's probably closer to 15.
And uh,
and he's 62.
And,
uh,
well he's never been better.
He's writing songs on a level that he's just as good as anything he's ever done.
And you know,
everybody else,
the rolling stones,
you see it's a revival tour.
They're just singing the thing equals this guy is still producing on a level
that he was producing at when he was 24 years old.
It's amazing.
It,
he's more than amazing because he literally,
and,
and this,
I was watching him and you know,
I was literally having,
this is going to sound really cheesy,
but I'm a huge fan of his,
I became an actor because of him.
I became a standup because they,
him guy listen to his songs because there was something in his voice.
But for me it was literally so overwhelming cause he's so timeless.
Like he's aligned with something to dude.
And it's because what motivates him is way more than,
than his own appetites.
And what he wants to do,
what motivates him is something much bigger than himself.
And I don't know what that is,
but probably you could feel it.
The love of all of those people.
He's got such a fanatical crowd.
Oh.
But it's also,
it's also though,
it's also about saying something man,
but you know of of all those people that are responding to what he said,
yeah,
that'd be an intense connection that Springsteen has to his fans.
It's because of,
you know,
like it's like born to run.
There's,
there's songs that like people just you,
you hear that and that's like a slice of history.
Go,
go to,
go to la,
go read the lyrics of greetings from Asbury park and darkness on the edge of
town because what he was doing there was literally like,
he kind of almost invented a language that changed a lot of like the artistic
landscape in New York.
At least.
You know Sam Shepard was writing plays based on that album.
Man,
no one has ever got rid of a chick that was a problem in his life and wrote a
better song about it than Springsteen did.
The brilliant,
she's the one who ever hear that.
I don't know that one,
but I know brilliant disguise that.
I remember hearing that because I was like early twenties when I,
when I heard that and I was,
you know,
always in terrible relationships,
always chaos.
Some,
some of them will,
it just didn't work out because it you,
some of it was because of her,
but you knew enough crazy people in your life at a certain
point to realize that you could get fucked in a relationship.
And when I saw that Bruce Springsteen got fucked and then I realized,
I was like,
oh see what happened?
She was really high so she pretended to be something and then he got close to
her and he got to know her and she was kind of a cut.
Right
Ray?
Go listen to she's jungle land.
She's the one.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
I know that song.
Fuck man.
I mean,
and back streets.
Yeah,
like back streets is about this by the way.
This is the,
the,
the brilliant disguise is like 15 years later,
oh my God,
he's that he,
not only is he prolific like that,
he's given songs away to people like the pointer sisters and Patti Smith.
And that was their biggest hit because when,
if there's a documentary called the promise,
where he'd,
he'd been born or when was the biggest album in the country and it was,
he was on the cover of Newsweek and Time magazine was 24 years old.
And then he went to write the promise,
I,
I'm sorry,
he went to write a,
um,
darkness on the edge of town and they wanted him to write more of the stuff from
born run like that Kinda,
that's what his fans want.
And not only that,
he was writing hit songs and giving them away.
And Steve Man's hand was like writing hit songs.
It's so fucking hard.
And he's giving them away.
And he comes into the studio and he goes,
well,
let's see what we're going to throw away today.
And he sees Steve Van Zandt go,
please don't throw that song.
Wait,
please don't.
It's so perfect please.
And he's like,
it doesn't fit in the album.
It just,
just doesn't fit in the album.
And he was so uncompromising and they said,
what drove?
He said,
I want it to be great because I knew I had an inside me and I wanted to be great
and I wanted to do something that nobody else.
I just didn't want to do anything derivative.
And I,
and I talked to him,
I talked to him for an hour and a half about songwriting,
which is kind of exciting and I,
I don't resist.
I went back stage a long time ago.
Jeremy Pivot and uh,
and I,
I literally talked about standup and about writing songs for an hour and a half.
It was just me,
him,
Jeremy,
his wife and my buddy Anthony Tan Backus,
who's going to be my next guest.
And the Brian Callen Pie.
Uh,
the Brian counts the 10 Backus.
He wrote warrior and he's,
we had a warrior was a good movie and that movie did not get nearly enough for
spray.
It really did.
I was surprised.
No,
it was,
my wife's loved it.
It's great movies.
It's a good movie.
The only unrealistic thing is that they fought two days in a row.
They didn't have to do that there.
That could have been worked out well because Anthony [inaudible] and Gavin,
who's the director and they wrote it,
they,
they're not,
they don't know a lot about fighting and that's all they were.
They were more concerned with the story,
you know,
but,
but it was still good.
It was still good even though that,
that was kind of nonsensical.
It was still still front.
It's a very good movie.
It's a great move of God damn.
Nick Nolte tease a mother,
father,
oh my God.
As a mother fucker who just showed up and just did that.
And did that take 50 times,
like literally there's like,
what do you,
what else do you want guys?
Oh my God.
If people don't know what we're talking about,
there's a breakdown scene.
Nick Nolte,
he's a recovering alcoholic who was a terrible father and he,
he basically gave birth to these two savages that meet in the finals of this MMA
tournament,
which by the way,
is a very accurate statement for many fighters.
There's a lot of fighters that grew up broken homes,
fucked up households.
You know,
a lot of,
a lot of fighters grew up,
you know,
in,
in dire straits as from some asshole father that and a lot of those asshole
fathers even wind up teaching those kids at first just like his dad did in this
movie.
So it was really accurate.
Like the way they did it.
It wasn't,
didn't seem fake.
The interactions like what's that dude's name?
Tom.
Tom Hardy.
Tom Hardy's,
what a bad mother fucker.
He's English to England.
But his interactions with the father,
we're so,
it was so realistic.
It was so believable.
Well Anthony Anthony had a very,
um,
it doesn't talk to his dad.
You know,
he had a very,
very tough childhood with his father.
His father was known as the guy who wrote it.
So,
you know,
uh,
if there's a lot of personal shit and he,
what's his last 10 back at back?
We just did a podcast and he was so,
it was so much fun to talk to them about art and about what's important.
And he's just one of those fucking guys who really,
I'll tell you what,
he nailed that movie cause that's a,
that's a tire genre.
It's the martial arts champion though.
The good guy's going to rise above and dude for his kids.
Right.
It's a tire.
John [inaudible] and he really connected and I was really good.
It was,
it sucked man.
I was really bummed out.
That movie didn't get nearly as much attention as it deserves out yet on DVD or
anything for a while is the number one DVD in the country.
It's a good fucking movie man.
I mean it's,
yeah.
Like I said,
the only thing that bothered me as a non realism about the upbeat,
you can't do,
if you tried to fight two days in a row,
your whole face would be swollen.
Your your hands.
You wouldn't be able to close your hands.
You can't do it.
You can't fight two days in a row.
It's too hard.
It's hard to fight more than once a day.
I've done it.
The last kickboxing tournament I fought three times in one day.
It's stupid.
Yeah,
it's,
it's wrestling tournaments.
We used to wrestle more than,
you know like if you go into like a a tournament sunrise,
it was two days long or even it was one day long.
You a lot of times you arrested at least three times.
Total problem was there was no head contact and wrestling and the head contact
and kickboxing and MMA like that's why you can't do it two days in a row.
You just can't,
you know,
you get rocked the the first day,
the next day you need fucking arrest man.
You can't be go getting actually actually really dangerous too if you have,
sure you have a mild concussion and you get hit again.
A lot of guys get concussed and still when it happens all the time they get in
cost and make it to the final round and the final round ends,
they go back to sit in the corner and the the the,
you know the corner,
we'll tell them the fights over.
That happened recently with Alex because Sarah's,
he got head kicked I think,
I believe it was in the second round.
He got head kicked and at the end of the third round he couldn't believe the
fight was over.
He's like,
what are you talking about?
The fight just started.
He goes and they go,
wow,
it's over.
He was like,
come on man,
you guys are playing with me.
Did he win?
Uh,
no he did not.
I believe he lost the decision.
It was a really close fight.
It was a crazy fight and he actually came back from getting head kicked and was
doing really well.
It was really amazing.
It was.
He just got hit with a really hard shot and that's just part of the game,
you know the,
the human head is,
what's it,
what's it doing to you that your ring side for all that violence?
I'm really numb to it.
It's really strange.
I've seen like street fights like up close and personal,
you know,
like I've seen shit go down like right in front of me.
No,
it doesn't even skip a beat.
It's like everything's moving in slow motion.
It's real weird.
Like,
I've,
I've gotten so
used to watching people beat the fuck out of each other on a high level,
like the highest,
the highest level in the world from feet away and then calling it,
you know,
and you know,
and it's an honor to do really,
I really say that.
And you know,
people say it sounds,
it almost sounds kind of like a false statement until you say it's an honor,
but it's one of those things.
There were the,
the word honor doesn't get used.
It gets judiciously kind of tossed out.
It's actually,
it's actually used it,
I don't think it's used enough.
Honor is something when a man talks about honor,
it's like,
oh,
you're old fashioned and stuff.
But honors very important.
It's a very important word and a sacred words.
It's very important.
That's why,
you know,
if I'm,
if I'm doing any sort of commentary on it,
I feel like I have this massive obligation to say exactly what I think is going
on.
If this guy,
you know why I think this guy is getting hit with this sorta,
sorta shot while he's moving a certain direction and it gets to the point
sometimes we're fighters will think that I'm being disrespectful and well I
don't know if that's true because I've never seen it.
I've had conversations with guys and I've got to tell him I'm,
I look good man.
I'm just critical.
If I can see it,
it's there.
If I can see a whole,
It doesn't mean you can't win with that whole,
but if I see a whole,
it's there and if you get mad at me,
cause I'm pointing out a hole in your game that doesn't,
that's silly.
You shouldn't,
I'm not criticizing you.
I'm,
I'm looking at the whole thing as a mathematical proposition and I'm saying,
here's an entry,
here's an entryway and here's,
here's the issue with this,
this one particular attack.
You've always had enormous respect for fighters.
And one of the things that I think that you're so good at and a lot of people
have said this,
is you take yourself completely out of the equation.
That's a very hard thing to balance actually,
because when you're calling a fight and you have to be,
you have to call if you,
you know,
you know fighting,
you've been watching it and you,
you know,
for many years now and you've been doing it,
you do see where there's a whole,
and so the balancing act as calling that but not,
not saying,
well I would have done something different.
You're always very careful about that.
You know,
that's the grossest thing that anybody ever does when they do commentary.
Well,
if I was me,
I would go in there and hit him with a left,
right?
No items.
You got no idea what it's like gross.
When I hear commentators,
not,
it doesn't happen very often with MMA commentators,
but with these prognosticator type characters that make predictions on fights,
I don't think he's going to be able to hand and they'll use like numbers,
like,
oh think he's gotta be able to handle it to three.
You know,
when he shoots the double and can't handle that two,
three [inaudible] kind of bananas you like,
you're going to predict the future.
Talk like,
stop.
I'll tell you something that I had an experience though.
My Buddy Karen Gallagher,
who was a stunt man,
but a lot of guys who are real MMA guys know,
know who he is because he came out of a University of Arizona,
Arizona state I think and uh,
uh,
was uh,
high level,
like a black belt in Jiu Jitsu from Hagen Machado's and I was a pro boxer by the
time he was in college.
He had 24 pro fights is a box or something and really knows his stuff.
And he's been teaching me like just,
he's got all kinds of crazy tricks and I watched the last fights with him.
I watched it,
I was with him and I was with a group of people.
I got witnesses like will Sasso there and stuff.
The dude not only called every fight,
but he was going to,
he told me what was going to happen before they would do it.
Like,
oh here comes the single leg here.
Cause it was so amazing.
And I said,
dude,
Karen,
you called every single fight and not only that,
you told me what was happening before.
He goes,
I haven't done that for 10 years,
but he knows the game that well,
but you'd never know it.
And he's just a stunt man now and you know he's to be,
he's gonna probably do commentary for somebody.
Dude,
he's,
he's not,
that's not his personality.
He's not going to do that.
He didn't just,
you know,
but if somebody knows if you,
you know the guy,
he's a hook them up with like shark fights or something.
He's done an awesome comic.
Uncanny.
He's one of those guys who's really intelligent.
Like he's a stunt man.
I know he's a high level fives.
Ilo.
I talk them into doing it and he's right.
He's also read every book.
I started mentioning books with Anthony who was a writer who wrote a novel.
He starts mentioning like everybody from Charles Bukowski to cure a whack to
fucking Norman mailer.
He's read them all in my read more than I have.
I go with the fuck.
I go,
have you read all these books?
He goes,
I read everything.
Did.
I mentioned obscure book called up called extreme fear that Sam Sheridan
recommended that I'm never reading now.
Fascinating.
He goes,
yeah,
I read it.
What the fuck you're talking about?
And it starts giving me a critique about it.
I was like,
suddenly they have a lot of free time.
I think he's got a lot of free time sometimes.
He's also really special smart guy.
Like I like,
he's a genuine friend,
like he's just a really,
really smart guy.
But I mean like when you're on a set,
like there's a lot of times like especially like,
I don't know if the fear factor said it was,
it was indicative of how it would be in a movie like stunt guys on a movie set,
but there's a lot of downtime.
There's a lot of times they're setting things up and there's a lot of,
he's also one of the few Steinman who,
who was a really actually a professional fighter and still rolls with Olympians
and still fucking has an MMA gym.
You know,
why don't you talk this guy into doing commentary,
man,
it seems like,
look,
a lot of people probably don't think that it could be possible.
That's why they don't want to do it.
They don't think that it could be real.
Well,
you know what I mean?
They don't even think about it.
This isn't even could pop into their head,
but the guy knows that much is the entertaining to talk to.
Yeah,
he's really,
really smart.
Then it sounds like he's perfect.
Somebody hire him.
He's probably better than me because nobody's better than you tell the UFC.
Nobody's better than you.
That's not true.
That's ridiculous.
I don't know anybody's better than you.
And I think Mike Goldman has unbelievable too.
He's great.
I think it's unbelievable.
You guys are the perfect fucking combination.
Kohlberg is a good dude.
You know?
One of the good things about like working with them.
I enjoy that guy.
I enjoy his company.
Yeah,
you've told me hanging out.
He's a nice guy,
man.
He's a sweetheart of a guy.
He's always nice.
He's always hugging everybody and always friendly.
He's a sweet,
positive guy.
You know?
So I liked being around him and he's fucking good.
He's,
he's a great play by play guy,
man.
He's smooth.
It's fuck.
He knows how to kill the poetic,
he's really poetic.
Like he's,
he's like,
I really,
people could take him and they criticize him,
but you're,
you're criticizing like one or two weird things and he might've said while we're
free ball and for fucking hours at a time,
six hours at a time,
several times a month,
you know,
you got to realize like you look man,
you're going to find some stupid shit that everybody says.
If you look at it for that long.
Speaking of free balling,
I just did the Adam Carolla podcast.
He's so unbelievable at coming up with like one premise and just being fucking
hilarious.
He was on the podcast.
I credited you as to saying that he's like the best guy at improvisation in and
coming up with like a whole rant on a set,
like the best rant guide,
like real and real bits.
Like literally like,
I'm busy.
I'm like,
I said,
do you ever do stand up?
He goes,
Nah,
I go,
you have five hours a fucking material now.
He's doing stand up now.
And I dunno,
he's,
he does well he does.
He does the podcast,
which is stand up in front of an,
oh no,
he's doing standup.
I was doing,
yeah.
Yeah.
He was doing regular standup.
He,
uh,
he did a show at the Irvine Improv and um,
it was a one of,
I did one of his live podcasts,
which I liked,
but I,
I don't like as much because it's just,
it's a completely different thing,
but when you're,
when you're live,
they're looking at me funny.
They're not going to be salient.
Well,
I felt like it's not even that it's a felt like,
why don't we even talk,
I should be doing standup right now.
I shouldn't be sitting here talking.
There's 300 people that want to laugh their ass off and I can do that.
I get you to laugh,
but let's just to stand up,
you know?
But I didn't want them putting my stand up on the Internet because it was like,
this is all stuff that I was going to put in my next album.
I was like,
I don't even know.
You can't just put that on your pod.
Right.
That's like Byron Allen,
you haven't seen that show.
He did called.
Um,
cuts the comic sit down or unleashed.
Meanwhile,
I get there,
I'll make suddenly you want me to do,
you're paying me 150 bucks or whatever it is to do like my act 20 minutes of my
ag.
Nah.
Yeah.
What the anchor not doing that and it gets,
they could fuck,
I'd probably sell it and syndication EOD,
right.
Like you'll be like,
hey,
what's up with your hair?
He prompts you and then you go in your bit and I'm watching guys,
I'm watching guys give up 20 minutes.
It took them like fucking three years.
I'm like,
you out of your fucking mind.
Well,
the worst is there.
There's some shows I'm sure where they own that material now and you're not
allowed to repeat that material.
You know,
if you do it,
I'm sure there's contracts that if I don't know what's actually though,
I just might think on showtime.
They,
they,
they were,
there's like dad some stipulation,
but I was able to do stuff on,
I just did the comedy central's Mashup where I have to rear up on a horse by the
way.
I mentioned that.
Whoa.
Yeah,
I'll be,
um,
I believe like if you,
they're going to take my standup bit where I rescue a bunch of women on
horseback and they're surrounded by wolves.
It's called the wolf.
Cause Yeah.
I talk about really heavy shit with my stand up.
But,
but um,
I I,
but I'm coming to your standup is so fucking silly and you're such a,
when I talked to you,
you're such an intense and serious guy and I'll do it.
Cause like yesterday I just did a fucking whole standup.
I did 20 minutes on saving a whale and they,
and they were fucking dying.
And I love the bit,
it's so funny.
So what's wrong with it?
You say that with like reluctantly nothing.
I don't know.
I just can't help it.
I start thinking silly.
Yes.
I just,
I,
I guess I just,
I start laughing at the idea of saving a fucking whale and then I didn't save it
and I had to sit on its blowhole kill it and no,
cause I didn't want it to die of dryness so I had to sit on its blow and uh,
anyway,
but it was fucking retarded.
But they loved it.
So,
um,
you know,
I don't know dude.
I uh,
uh,
now I'm now my next hour that I'm working on.
It's a little bit different.
I'm dealing with larger motifs and larger teeth.
She'd been living in Venice too long.
So we need to get you to come back out here to Saint Gabriel Valley.
I got to get to find that.
Brian,
what the fuck did he just say?
So you understand that at all guys.
Sorry if someone said that in front of you,
would you get disgusting guy?
Sorry,
I'm very educated.
I'm highly educated,
highly educated,
sophisticated zip up boots.
Count Myself.
Got It all.
It is weird.
It is weird seeing you hang out with different people though.
Cause it seems like certain people you act different,
you know,
like you're more sillier when you're with the me mean.
I'm a,
because I mean I'm a chameleon.
You mean like my sister who calls me the chameleon?
You know what my buddy Anthony Tan back has said about me.
He goes,
you know Brian Walks,
if Brian walks,
it takes a walk with seven Cherokees when he,
well,
you know,
it comes back a Cherokees.
I was like,
ah,
fuck,
shut off.
It's true that I had to be that way as a kid.
I had to blend in when I moved.
Moved here is very unique.
I mean it's not like you're,
you're very unique,
but I try to be,
oh you should short bus unique either your your unique dude.
But yeah,
you and I always wind up with caveman conversations.
I always go fucking right to though at the bottom of a man's soul what we think
about violence and sexuality and you know,
all this fucking societies and illusion and when it crumbles down,
that fucking guy is going to fall apart.
But that's what I hear.
You and I have always had this friendship where like,
like where no matter what,
if we're lying to each other,
like if we're just,
we were like,
we just don't want to deal with the truth right now.
We'll just start saying something like,
and like I would be like,
I really love her.
And he'd be like,
Hey,
who are you fucking talking to now?
You down.
I'm like,
but I live with her.
Yeah.
So what,
you don't love her break up with her immediately.
You know,
I could never get away.
We can never really get away with like lying to each other.
You know,
you were just too good of a friend to have these crazy girls who were there.
And when I say crazy girls put folks,
I'm not an invasive sort of a a friend when it comes to friends,
girlfriends,
like Brian can tell you,
I'm usually a pretty supportive,
right when you say Brian.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
And I did it.
A lot of crazy girls and he stayed a lot of crazy girls.
But my fun but my take on it was always just be sweet to them,
be nice to him,
fuck the shit out of them.
And if they leave they leave.
You know that's how you go.
But with you,
you had a totally different kind of crazy and developed an addiction.
You had a fascination with girls who were gigantic problems.
Brian's girls are sweet girls.
They just,
what happens in life?
You'd take a left when you should've taken a ride.
You get stuck,
you can't pay your rent.
There's a lot of shit that happens to people in life.
So he's dealing with essentially sweet girls that go down a bad track.
Your dealing with fucking crazy people all different ways you can lose your
fucking house.
Oh,
not just lose your house,
your life,
your life.
You had,
he had a few of 'em man where he would bring over like it was,
it was like Joe Lewis,
his bum of the month club,
who's great,
bring over all these new silly bitches that he was dating.
One of them I called bunch of naps.
She came over,
I met her cookies.
Yeah,
she comes over and I go there,
check,
it looks like she needs a bunch of naps.
Right.
And then 10 minutes into hanging out at my house,
Oh my God,
I'm so tired.
She takes her shoes off and curls up on the couch with a fucking cash.
It was,
I literally,
she was like having owning a high tech patch.
It was so strangling.
She's my pet.
It was so strange.
I have never met like,
uh,
more cat,
like human rights.
I've never met a person who just like had no desire to have an intelligent
conversation,
just wanted to take naps.
I talked to this guy and this is fucking,
I talked to is awesome dude who's like a well known,
um,
like um,
uh,
like a,
a psychiatrist,
got his PhD,
he's really smart guy.
And he said a lot of times people in relationships,
like he works with a lot of like couples and stuff like that.
And then addicts and stuff.
He said,
and he said,
a lot of times what human beings do is we apply a construct on someone.
So they'll,
you'll find somebody that looks the part and then you just apply a construct.
You just go,
oh,
that's who you are.
You're this girl.
You really like to work out.
Yeah.
You're the j crew girl.
I'm on on,
on a fucking on the front of a sail boat.
That's what I want to date me.
While the girl was like,
I'm from fucking Michigan.
I never been on a sailboat in my fucking life.
I like to do drugs every day.
What are you talking about?
No,
you know,
why were you trying to construct the,
that sort of a,
a really non realistic reality though all the time?
I don't know because it wasn't like,
it was really strange.
It's like that's the kind of behavior that you get from people that have a hard
time meeting girls,
but you had no problem.
You can girls.
It wasn't that at all.
You are not shy.
You're always charming and you're always funny.
So I mean,
I can't remember a time where you're like,
dude,
I can't meet girls.
And just tired of being alone.
It was never that.
It was,
it was you,
you know,
for whatever reason would wind up getting,
I can't crazy girl like this.
There were so nuts,
dude,
that I was trying to figure out.
I spent many an hour by myself thinking about you after many of our crazy
adventures,
thinking about you going,
how did this happen?
How did this guy get to this state of mind where he lets this person in his life
and then he can't see that.
I don't understand that.
This is what I'm hanging out with you.
I'm like,
here's this insightful,
intelligent,
objective self deprecating guy who's really well read and yet he's hanging
around with legit methods.
You were hanging around with like scary people there were like,
no,
I really don't know what that was.
I think part of it was just,
um,
I think what it was was I'd go,
oh,
that's a project and I can save that person.
Yeah.
I think that was a lot.
And that was,
I found that very intriguing where I'd say,
you know what,
all you need is someone like me to change your life and I know how to help you.
And it took me a long time to realize that that is the dumbest shit you can
advocate for it.
Anybody dead fucking end.
You never want to do that shit.
My goodness.
It is.
You know,
you never want to do that because you can't.
my father said
something interesting to me the other day.
He said,
look,
you want to give advice to a kid.
Very different.
Don't ever get advice ever,
ever.
To An adult.
Even if even if that can use it.
I'm never doing,
I should.
Yeah,
but I,
the guys name,
he's headed toward a wall.
He goes,
that's right.
They know their head into a wall.
Never.
This is your dad.
Yeah.
And he said,
this isn't your dad do a talk show.
I got to get him on my fuck because one of my favorite people in the world,
he's the greatest because he lived here.
He said,
why don't you get it?
Can I go say,
can I go on with your dad?
Oh,
that'd be great.
Please.
Well,
he's a great guy to talk to about politics,
about the state of the fucking world.
I would love about everything cause he's been in a hundred countries.
Oh Geez.
He's going to Italy right now just to brush up on his Italian.
I'm like,
why are you doing that?
He goes,
I dunno,
I'm going to Rome for three weeks.
Wow.
He was the greatest.
He said a sock and he was like,
we were talking about like having a,
you know when when you're with a woman you want to be able to talk to her and
sometimes you can't.
He goes talk to her.
What would you want to talk to her?
I've been married to your mother for 50 years.
I want to talk to her and I'm not gonna.
It's ridiculous.
It's got to work.
Got To fucking work stupid.
It was so great.
He's such a bottom,
bottom line guy and and has read everything but is also just a real man,
a real,
a real fun.
Sounds like a fun guy to talk to him.
He's more of those,
I call them every day when I need it.
When I,
when I want to talk about something in the news or saw,
talk about,
just get crazy with them.
How deep do you go in the rabbit hole?
As deep as it gets.
Really,
you're that guy where you can go all the way into the rabbit hole with him.
Like personal secrets.
Fuck yes.
Anything.
Oh fuck yes.
And,
and be careful by the way,
cause he'll fucking,
you know,
he'll,
he'll smell you.
He'll smell.
You're like,
oh my God,
smell you.
How about this?
I'll give you a great story.
Ready?
Watch this.
My buddy comes in because I swear to God,
I'm with my dad,
we're in my office,
my buddy comes in,
he just happened to be around cause he was gonna,
you know,
he just comes and goes,
Hey Brian,
how you doing?
I go,
Hey,
well let's say his name is Jeff.
Hey Jeff,
what's up?
And he goes,
no,
I'm not taking.
I go,
I'm good.
And he goes,
all right man,
I love this question because says a couple of words.
And he goes,
hey Ms. Guy doing nice to meet you.
Yay.
And he just leaves.
And My,
my father,
my father goes,
what's that got to do?
And I go,
oh,
he's,
he's a writer.
My father,
oh,
I suspect that's not gonna work out for him.
And I go and I go,
how did you know that?
And he goes,
pattern recognition.
I've been around,
I'm 71 years old.
That's how pattern rather than Russian mission.
So he's like that guy from the Bill Ben Stiller movie where he has like the
human lie detector on it.
That's what he can read you in a heartbeat,
dude.
He can read,
you can see you walk across the street.
He knows your whole fucking life.
Then again,
how the fuck are you so bad at that?
Well,
I'm actually good at it.
I choose to ignore it.
Really?
Yes,
I did actually.
I think I'm very good at it,
but when I see a project I go,
hey,
I need to help you.
So you almost,
well,
there was a self destructive aspect to you.
Uh,
that always disturbed me being your friend.
That's what would drive me nuts,
you know?
And it was a distraction and it rocked.
It hurt my career by the
way.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It hurt my career and it hurt my relationships with people that were significant
in my life and yeah.
Um,
and I think a lot of that self sabotage,
we all go through that stuff.
You go through it,
man,
you will weigh less than,
than anybody.
I knew actually you were always very good at cutting out the fat and I kept it
because I wanted an excuse maybe to,
uh,
you know,
I mean it was like a parachute.
You know what I mean?
I think,
um,
there's very few reasons in life to give yourself more problems and if you can
find all your own problems and address them,
I try to deal with all your own problems and be real honest about that.
Then it makes it really easy to see other people's problems.
But I've found that in my life when I wasn't being honest with myself about my
own problems,
when I had issues,
when I had unresolved things in my mind,
just when I was a real young man,
I was still growing up and trying to get over my fucked up childhood.
I found it much more difficult for me to see problems and other people because
of the shield that I put on recognizing my own issues.
I wasn't as intuitive or insightful when it came to recognizing other people.
As I get older and I became as honest as as humanly possible,
which is how I am now,
um,
now,
then it became where I just see it everywhere.
That became really obvious.
That's what I have now become obsessed with and that's why I don't suffer fools
anymore.
Like that's why,
because what I'm,
what I'm very interested in is figuring out,
I want to stay as undiluted as I can and as authentic when I was watching
Springsteen,
but I,
the word that kept popping into my head was just authentic.
He's never lying.
It's everything about him,
the way he dresses,
the way everything about it and nothing is in his way.
There's no resistance is why he can do a back bend and touch his head at 62.
Why,
why?
You can literally back then he went all the way back and hit his head.
He can,
he can run.
He's 62.
That's amazing.
On stage,
on stage,
on Hollaback.
At 62.
And I went and I went,
that guy is so out of his own way.
You know,
I've said this before,
maybe on the podcast,
but it's one of my favorite metaphors that Michelangelo said when he was Clark.
He said his name,
I mean,
when,
sorry guys,
I speak a die.
Uh,
sorry.
There are no girls here.
Okay.
Sorry.
When Michelangelo,
uh,
said,
when he carved the David,
the statue of David and he had this piece of marble and he said,
and this is a great metaphor for art,
he said,
it's already in there.
I just had to get all the shit out of the way.
And he said,
that's how you should look at yourself as a human being.
You're born and you acquire a lot of shit as you're,
as you're growing up,
right?
So as you grow up,
a lot of Shit's put on you,
but your family,
uh,
how they define you,
what they,
what they do to you.
Uh,
PA school,
high school,
the trauma of school,
the grief you go through,
you know,
your body isn't what you wanted to do,
those losses and stuff and you put on a lot of stuff,
you,
you come to the world when you're ready to take it on at 30 with a whole lot of
fucking baggage.
And a lot of it's negative,
you know?
And the,
the job then is to figure out a way to get that stuff off you,
to shed that stuff and get back to who you really are,
the authentic you.
And that to me is at least as a comic and as somebody who writes and stuff,
that's,
that's all I think about now.
You know,
what is,
what is how honest can I truly be with my expression?
Even if I'm being silly and like talking about saving a whale,
there's a lot of me in there that I'm,
I'm talking about,
you know,
and especially now the stuff that I'm working on now,
just,
you know,
being a father and things like that and that responsibility and what that really
means and,
and,
and uh,
with my daughter and,
and not being able to show us her a part of me,
uh,
and,
and who,
who I want,
she's going to model them and she dates after me.
So I got to be a fucking,
I got to be the,
I got to be her hero.
I got to be the guy that she actually,
I don't want to Dayton the guy I used to be,
you know what I mean?
So there's all those responsibilities that you start taking on as you get older.
But so much of that is,
and so much of fucking thought,
you know,
but I've got to think,
they act like it's an active process.
Thinking and being creative is actually learning what not to think about because
the rest of it comes to it.
There's the that that's a,
that's a real philosophy.
If you can open yourself up and think of thinking as being more of a channel for
what's available to you,
that that's a very important distinction.
This notion that they'd see,
a lot of people come and say,
well,
I'm missing something.
I'm missing something that I have to add to my arsenal.
No.
In fact,
what you're probably doing is there's,
there's something you've got to let go of and when you let go of that,
you'll get what you're looking for or you'll find that that that's a,
that's a fundamental difference in thinking about things.
And I think a lot of times we're taught,
hey,
you,
you're missing something.
You got to add to your,
your,
you got to put another Arrow in your quiver.
In fact,
you might have the,
the,
the uh,
better,
better advice may may be to say,
you got to let some stuff go,
man.
You're holding on to some stuff.
You've got to let some stuff go.
You're still defining yourself along lines that are not helpful to you.
You're still,
you still have people in your life that are not your friends even though they
seem like they are,
you still have,
you're still doing a job that you hate because it's an excuse to not do not go
for what you really want.
There are a lot of things that you should be deleting.
You should be taking out of your life and,
and,
and then there will be room for something that's much better.
That's a,
that's a very,
it's a scary way to think of it but I don't think we talk about that enough.
I don't think that that is something that is a given enough voice to
definitely something when I get older I feel myself doing that.
Just like deleting shit out of your life that day constantly bugs you in HR.
Like if it's people or friends or,
I mean that's one of the biggest things I've been running into lately is just
like how many people that that I keep in like,
like almost a book.
Like Hey,
this person's my friend,
this person was my friend.
But then actually going through it,
I'm like,
why am I friends with this person?
Yeah.
There's a million other people that want to be my friend that I could just start
hanging out with that could just take this place and this person's positive,
you know?
Yeah.
We'll watch when people go into a room,
like a lot of times my mother will go into a room and find everything that's
dangerous in a room.
She'll look at the world and try to chew.
She can see a whole bunch of things that are dangerous.
How many times you wash people,
talk to their kids and say,
be careful my break your arm.
Careful of that.
Don't do that.
You're always putting restrictions on people.
Now you've got to do that to an extent with children,
of course.
But we grow up with that,
with that,
um,
that kind of guidance.
And a lot of times they mean well,
but it's the wrong guidance.
It's getting in your way,
you know?
Yeah,
for sure.
There's definitely patterns that people can sit down early in their life and
then continue to follow those patterns and have them not be productive at all.
It's a real dangerous thing about human beings is that we operate in patterns
and once a pattern has been established,
even if it's completely ridiculous,
we'll follow it.
Whether it's circumcision or whether it's cutting holes and your lip to stretch
it out,
to put them fucking plate in it.
Like those crazy women answering the,
why do they do that?
Well,
they,
because the pattern has been established and they just fall right into it and it
can get real weird man.
It can.
There can be patterns for cannibalism.
The semen ingesting tribes of New Guinea.
Do you know about all that?
Yep.
How fucking nutty is that?
If you don't know the story behind that,
just look up seamen tribe's new Guinea and I,
there's no way we could delve into hell fucking unbelievably bizarre and
twisted.
It is,
but there's a whole tribe and not just one,
but hundreds of them that live in New Guinea that they,
they're feeding kids sperm.
They're in jail.
They're making them suck their dicks and they're fucking them in the ass to make
these kids grow older.
And they even in fact believe some of them believe that the only way that a
child develops semen is it has to be planted in his body by fucking them in the
ass.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean,
how did that pattern get gold street history's riddled with those kinds of
crazy,
you know,
I mean,
Charles Taylor and one of the,
one of the slogans I just was listening to NPR,
Charles Taylor was the president of Liberia and there was,
I mean,
Charles Taylor,
when he came to power,
he took,
uh,
what's his name?
Uh,
go.
They made him eat the,
made the guy eat his own ears and they videotaped it.
Right?
That's,
yeah.
Then they killed him.
They,
they,
when they,
when he overthrew that government,
uh,
Samuel Doe,
who was the price,
I believe the current president of Liberia,
he and his henchmen and Charles Taylor was at military guy,
I think a major in the army or a general,
and they had them on a plane and they staged the COO out on the plane.
And before they killed him,
they made him meet his own ears.
Wow.
They made him on pain,
rock Johnson.
He was a bad guy and they made a meat eaters,
one of yours.
And I think another part of his body.
And then they,
uh,
and then I think they actually,
then they castrated and let them bleed out.
Oh Geez.
Point is that he was a ruthless guy and he's,
he's the one who said Foday Sankoh who had an Iberia and bleed out on a plane.
Yes.
What puddle that must've been,
yeah.
I don't know all the details,
but it was a very brutal way of coming to power.
And Charles Taylor was associate about just,
just convicted in the Hague by the way,
just convicted for war crimes and crimes against humanity.
But he was the one that said the flood,
they Sanko who is the,
the warlord and Sierra Leone.
He said,
you have to brutalize the people so badly that they have no other choice but to
vote you in because they're so there too afraid not to vote for you.
And that was,
that was funny sample.
We used to go from town to town and said,
if you voted,
if you voted for the government,
and currently we're going to cut all your hands off and he'd cut everybody's
hands off.
Oh my God.
I Scott and,
and what,
what Charles Taylor,
Charles Taylor said,
one of the slogans when he was running for president was,
you killed my mother.
You killed my father,
but I'm still gonna vote for you.
And it worked for him.
It worked for them.
That's how insane.
That's how insane a mind indoctrination can become if somebody is vicious enough
to do it or manipulate it enough.
There was an,
uh,
an ancient Japanese story that Dunkin told me about,
a king or an emperor who,
uh,
hired someone to keep his concubines in line.
He hired a,
this,
a,
this famous military adviser to keep this concubines in line.
Concubine is a prosperous today.
So he said,
if you can,
if you could keep my concubines in line,
then surely you could run my army.
So,
hmm.
What the guy did as he stepped up and he said,
uh,
he clapped his hands and he said,
listen to me,
I'm going to say move to the left.
And you move to the left.
Ready?
And he claps his hands.
They moved to the left,
but a couple of them moved to the right.
And some of them don't do anything.
So he says it,
I'm going to say it one more time.
I'm going to clap my hands.
And when I say move to the left,
you all move to the left.
So it does it again.
And again.
Half of them don't pay attention.
So he takes the emperors favorite concubine.
He brings her in front of everyone and he cuts her fucking head off Jesus
Christ.
And the emperor tries to stop him.
The emperor runs in and he goes,
no,
not her,
not her.
She's my favorite.
He goes,
no.
you cannot win a war if you're not willing to do what must be done.
And he goes,
this is what must be done.
Cods her fucking head off and everybody,
and then he claps his hands and he said,
when I say move to the left,
you move to the labs and they fucking fell in line and everyone fell in love.
They knew that that was his favorite one.
That's why he took the favorite one and cut her head off.
Because there's certain things you have to do if you want to run shit.
Right.
And that's one.
And this is a,
that was,
you know,
a true military move.
Well,
what's interesting about that's how,
that's how every society was ruled,
especially with the Romans.
The Romans basically in this book,
extreme fear.
The Romans literally just train their army and constant warfare.
Their training was constant and they kept,
and they,
and their battles were as simulated.
Their,
their training was as close to reality as they could simulate.
And they were a very hard group.
One of the reasons being when you want it,
if you,
if you want to be ready for combat,
you know,
you know this from MMA,
you,
you better be,
you better be training like in,
in that mimic
combat as close as you can.
And we all know this but,
but,
uh,
one of the things that's interesting about that way of ruling,
which was always by the sword and extreme measures,
was that the political experiment that happened in this country 250 years ago in
Philadelphia,
the drafting of the federalist papers and the constitution was in fact
completely the opposite.
It was,
it was the notion that,
that in fact,
um,
you as a ruler,
where we're,
we're,
we're the servant of and for the people.
And that was what was such a radical notion,
this idea that there was not going to be a king and all powerful king.
It's why when George Washington and said,
I don't want to be king,
I am not a king.
We are not going to have a king in this country.
We're going to have a president who's voted in by the people at that time.
It was,
you know,
white landowning people.
But it was still a radical notion.
It started it,
the kernels of that began in,
in,
in England where the,
the,
the king actually had to start being,
uh,
listening to the parliament.
But it was such a radical notion that you had a group of people that were not
military,
that didn't have guns yet.
They had,
they had the authority,
um,
and the,
the balancing power of the authority to,
to make laws,
to raise taxes,
to pass taxes.
But they were ultimately at the behest of the population they were serving,
never been done before.
And what it gave rise to is the strongest,
most innovative country in the world.
In a lot of ways.
If you talk to political philosophy,
you know,
people who are,
who are,
uh,
political,
you know,
um,
uh,
people who make politics life that,
that experiments solve the political problem,
they solve the political problem.
No one ever argues about the,
the fallibility of the constitution.
It's always a question of how you interpret it.
But we always stay within the confines of the Constitution,
which is kind of amazing.
And it's such a radical difference.
Like that is how you control people.
It is how you control people.
Look at Russia.
Russia's run by a group of ex KGB guys who are all military guys there.
One resources,
oil,
they have a lot of money.
When was the last time you saw anything come out of Russia?
Like a car,
like a computer or even clothing.
What innovation has ever come out of Russia?
Nothing but minerals.
Nothing but oil.
You know why?
Because that kind of thinking,
that kind of brutality that kind of might makes right.
Actually at the end of the day makes a country weaker.
We'll do it just to make it stronger.
They were so good with,
uh,
with rocketry though.
They were amazing.
They were innovative.
They were,
yes.
When it came to the space race,
it's really incredible.
Oh,
you mean the Soviets,
Soviets and it's,
it's fascinating.
It's also how their designs were parallel to like what Wernher von Braun was
doing,
but yet
different like different sorts of setups with the rockets.
And they had a little bit of a different thing though.
The Soviets were first of all had a very rich tradition of art and literature
and culture.
And they also,
you know,
back in the day,
communism for a lot of Soviets,
a lot of Russians was an ideal.
An idealistic was,
it was an ideology they really believed in.
And so there was a,
for a long time,
a real communal effort.
There was this notion that we as a country are not only doing the right thing,
but we're going to beat the American,
the imperialists at their own game.
Well,
they would,
I was going to say as they really are very innovative when it came to a certain
aspects of technology.
Mike Swick,
uh,
you know Mike,
the guy a out of San Jose,
the fighter UFC guy,
really good dude,
um,
was working in a u s embassy in Russia a long time ago.
And he said they found like they would find like little hearing devices and shit
that the Russians had put into their,
their stuff to look at them and to listen in on them.
And one of them they found was powered by the swaying of the building.
They had never seen anything like it.
You know what though?
Had to like back engineer this fucking thing and go like if you look at it
though,
the Cold War on what one the war was the fact that the Soviets ultimately,
actually from a technological point of view,
first of all they stole,
remember they stole from the Rosenbergs was that the guys that were put to death
by I believe Truman,
um,
the,
the couple that sold the Soviets,
the weapon that the technology for the nuclear weapon and really,
yes.
So Soviet system,
he's got there,
got there,
got the,
got the bomb from us.
They have through espionage.
But having said that,
I read some sh what did I read something about that being a bad decision.
Well,
what about the fact that,
that we uh,
Truman put them both to death.
The,
the,
what the hell?
I can't believe I'm rose acres.
I can't believe I'm blanking on their name.
Your ex flex.
It's that it's the Rosen.
It's the,
um,
I can't believe I'm,
it's Roseburg or road Rosenberg.
It was a,
it was a couple that sold the Soviets,
the secrets,
the secret to the bomb.
And then that started the arms race and Ethel Rosenberg.
Yes,
thank you.
And they were put to death for selling the soviets and the Soviets got a lot of
their technology not from within their own sort of,
you know,
their own laboratories but from other lab,
other places.
And then,
you know,
worked on it.
But one of the things that the Soviets lost,
like for example,
their Mig fighter jets couldn't fly as hire as fast.
You know,
why they couldn't come up with the kind of steel,
when you deal with pro fighter jets,
it's all about like how,
how,
what kind of temperature resistance steel you can come up with.
That way you can burn hotter and our RF fourteens and efficacy sixteens at
fifteens or whatever could burn fuel at a much higher temperature without
melting the metal so we could fly higher and faster.
They couldn't keep up with us.
But you heard about this new thing that went,
what is it?
180 times faster than the speed of sound?
Brian,
what was this new uh,
experimental craft?
If they had,
I didn't hear you didn't hear about this on Twitter?
No,
dude.
What?
Somebody who's NASA spacecraft that they've developed it for?
It's a drone right now,
but it went 100,000 some insane miles per hour limit.
Let me,
let me give you the exact,
that this is what race has all kinds of questions.
Did you see that Cheetah,
that fucking mechanical Cheetah that they're going to put guns on?
It runs like a Cheetah and one's like robotics.
The Darpa robots,
transformers,
dude,
robotics are,
are,
we're going to have like all kinds of crazy shit.
It raises a lot of questions,
man.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
In other words,
we get that good at killing.
What does that mean?
Right.
So that drone,
that would be pretty much as fast as a bullet.
What this fucking thing apparently went so fast that it peeled the skin off of
it.
What they,
they,
they anticipated that the speed was going to peel some of it off,
but apparently appealed all of it off.
Peel skin yet another and yet another device where we're,
we're not going to need soldiers anymore.
I might,
that's my joke where I go to the war here,
I was going to in 20 years is going to be the Chubby dude with huge thumb
muscles.
Smells like Doritos and we'd,
cause he's,
he's working toggle switches.
Yeah,
we were,
you know,
you think about how good guys get at video games where it's so frustrating to
play though.
Imagine if those guys are in control of like some sort of a death machine with
no lag time.
So that means Korea wins,
right?
A hypersonic glider.
And then what they're saying is the skin was peeled off by this speed of this
fucking thing.
This is a,
this is incredible.
This is another Darpa project,
Darpa there.
So you video games are responsible thing.
Video Games were responsible for top gun fighter pilots and,
and for Swat team guys,
he'd get these 16 year olds to come in and they can fly a plane after learning a
little bit on the simulator as well as any top gun fighter pilot or shoot more
accurately than the best sniper.
You know,
why they'd been playing fucking gun video games and fighter pilots shit since
they were three years old.
So they just,
they had that hand eye coordination.
Yeah,
the uh,
the ability to aim it.
There was a shooting in a school where the kid shot eight kids in his classroom
and none of the Swat team,
when they looked at the,
what happened,
he was shooting kids in the head as they were running and catching them and
headshots squeezing them off and they were like,
we don't have anybody who can do that.
I mean that's kind of a physical assault side thing.
He,
but the kid had been doing that,
he'd been shooting whatever,
you know.
Yeah.
So he was,
by the time he was 16 he was an expert with a,
with a gun.
But wonder if there's going to be less car accidents because of video games for
kids or I wonder like if you were to go back like 10 years,
like if they have better hand on coordination.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
Cars are also going to be communicating with each other thing though,
you know,
especially when you're shifting gears and stuff.
So this thing went 20 times faster than the speed of sound.
Why fast enough to fly from New York to Los Angeles in 12 minutes?
I'm gonna tell you how fast that is.
750 miles an hour as the speed of sound.
It went for nine minutes.
It,
it flew.
But apparently this thing could go.
It could go from New York to La in less than 12 minutes.
My fucking God.
What?
What was that?
It could go to New York to La and less than 12 minutes.
1,000 times faster than this speed.
One t times the speed of sound.
Okay.
And you know how fast that is?
That's 15,000 miles an hour.
Wow.
Actually thirteen thousand thirteen thousand miles an hour.
That's what this thing is.
Okay.
The result gaps is speed.
It's actually a little less than 20 times.
Well,
you know what,
actually I think it's capable of more than that.
I think what they're saying is if 13,000 miles an hour,
the skin peeled off of it,
thousand miles an hour.
Oh my God.
13,000 miles in an hour.
What are you talking about?
Jesus Christ.
Think about how fucking fast that they would be flew to New York and how long?
12 minutes from where?
Well it couldn't make it cause it burnt to death and nine minutes post the fuel
at all.
No Adderall.
It's coke.
It runs on coke.
Exactly.
Knew what if they found the cocaine was like the best fuel ever.
Well in some ways it is and you could use it to get to the moon.
No problem.
A while burn for a little while.
You feel visible.
If you figured out how to put it into some sort of an engine that made a
combustion,
it's only possible with cocaine and,
well that's it.
That's the thing.
It's like trying to come up with like,
like you know,
fuel that really is that way.
I guess we are,
well we were going to have to because it's going to run out of fucking oil.
It's going to,
it might be a hundred years from now.
It might be 50 years,
but eventually it looks like it's gonna run.
The cars are already running.
I mean I got,
you don't even have a car.
So it's a dishwasher.
A man who's so manly.
Why do you not have a Shelby Mustang?
Because I come with me,
come with me to the dealership.
Let me tell you something.
I don't think,
you know,
I think you're missing out because I don't think you've ever experienced like
you and I go on to buy a game.
Bread.
Pitbull.
Yeah,
I remember that very well.
Very well.
And I had to come late duty.
It's,
we go find this complete bad and know how to draw.
Drive a stick shift,
right?
Yeah.
You're going to drive my gt three when we get out of here.
Okay.
You have some money.
You should get a fun car.
I shouldn't even have to floss.
Get a God Damn Mustang gt or a Ford edge or Ford edge is not.
Not what I'm talking about.
I'm going to coffee.
Tea was,
they're fun.
They're fun.
It's a fucking big v eight 400 something horsepower,
but I drive too much.
I've got a tough fill it up with gas all the time.
So you go to the gas station,
it takes five minutes.
Don't be a pussy.
You know when you need gas,
you don't need gas.
Get yourself what?
God Damn Mentally car.
You would love it.
Call it God damn.
Dodge SRT eight challenger.
That's what fun of those channels has.
That's what I'll talk about.
See,
he's happy.
I bet it sticks you with a race.
I bet he's happy.
I was in it yesterday.
I got seasick.
I got carsick.
I bet he was happy though.
Did you feel you can't drive slowly?
He looked pretty happy though.
Didn't he?
CanNot drive slowly.
Hanes is giant.
Va has cars need to be monsters and totally inappropriate.
It's perfect.
It's wheels or that fat.
He's enjoying his life.
Yeah.
The challenger,
there's kind of scrawny.
We,
he's got the,
he's got the racing,
he's got the SRE.
Expensive package.
That's great.
Those cars are a,
they don't have that well that well because it's a big car.
It's like more than 4,000 pounds I believe.
Yeah.
You mean even though I have the Shelby gt 500 and that's like 3,800 or
something.
That's,
they're pretty heavy in comparison to like the Porsche is like 3000 pounds.
Porsche is really light and when you get a big heavy car like that,
it's fucking really hard to make handle.
But in straight lines and in some ways the challenges like one of the last real
old school muscle cars really,
and the,
and the Mustang Gt,
you know the,
the,
the gt 500 the Shelby,
it's,
it's still stupid.
It's like way too much power for the bay.
And then the new ones that are coming out with new ones that have 650
horsepower,
mine has five 50 and it's ridiculous.
Five five,
five 50 and it's sounds majestic.
It makes your balls feel good.
Like when you hear the noise.
See I,
I've driven other cars.
Like if I had to pick what's my best car,
I would say the Porsche,
the Gt three,
the race car.
That's a great car,
but it's not as stupid.
Put a big stupid grin on your face.
Fun is Shelby's more fun because it's got a big dumb and Jen and when you hit
the gas he goes,
but it's an American.
It's American versus German.
It's America.
Fuck yeah,
it's got low end torque.
Like it throws you back in the seat with a Ba.
They should have made this should've just added balls to it.
This challenge is the only starts off at 24 and it gets 27 miles per gallon,
which is actually really good.
It gets 15 car.
It's a fucking,
your car only goes 52.
If you drive like a girl,
you're telling her,
you tell me that,
that the uh,
that actually it gets not as good gas mileage as your BMW or something.
An m on an m three,
not even a regular BMW if you take it on a track.
Oh really?
Yes.
Top gear.
I love them to death.
Those guys out of the England,
Jeremy Clarkson,
uh,
went around a track and he had a,
a BMW m three,
and he floored it and the guy tried to keep up with him or he didn't know he had
to keep up with the guy in the Prius.
That's all he had to do.
And the BMW,
it was much easier for the BMW to keep up like a really easy for the BMW and
easy pace,
like 90 miles an hour or something like that.
Where's the Prius was fucking struggling to keep it up.
So the Prius actually burnt more gas.
It's up.
He says,
Shit,
you're a man.
What about the euro man?
And get away from me with that.
You need a Goddamn challenger with a sketch shift to you.
Pussy.
Don't get the automatic traffic.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's part of being a man.
We gotta be able to fucking keep it in neutral.
Would you really recommend a challenge that,
fuck yeah,
I would recommend.
Why didn't know is this cheap food?
I would want my Joe gets irrational a sec.
Come on baby.
It's traffic in La.
Stick shift.
Yeah.
I want an horsepower.
I might buy one.
Uh,
one of those when my mustangs leases up.
I might,
I might get one of the fucking buy a horse sex.
I would trade my car in.
I,
yeah,
that's a good car.
If you're going to trade it in for a challenger,
that's a great car.
Can,
what are you dry?
So make solid cars,
man.
And they're fun to drive.
It's sounds cool.
It's easy to see out of,
you know,
gimme gimme gimme another car.
What about that?
Get them manly car.
I can't tell you what you should get.
We should get,
it's like a fucking nine 11.
Get a new Porsche.
They have a new nine nine one oh yeah.
You don't even have to drive a stick shift.
They have a dual clutch transmission that paddle shifting.
Really if you got some cash and you ready to party,
it's fun.
You don't have to drive your responsible.
You just merging on the highway.
Drove I drove a Arnold Schwarzenegger is old Porsche cause my buddy had it in
his lot and I was like in first gear the whole time.
I can't go anywhere.
Well traffic.
Yeah well you know you're going to get a little bit of that but you can,
if you want to buy a new car you can get a car that has a dual clutch.
I bought the three 35 I BMW a great car.
I couldn't drive it though either.
I was just always,
I can never open it up as long as it just felt like it was,
it wanted to go and I could and I felt like I kept,
I was keeping a dog in a cage really.
Cause I have the m three and it always feels like that's like my favorite.
The way you live out there,
you can,
you got some open road too,
even if you don't,
you know,
I think the monitoring I do fascinating about it.
Yeah.
I love technology and my favorite technologies like interactive technology is
cars because they're connected.
Well,
first of all,
because I'm an idiot and I see these amazing things like computers and I'm like,
who the fuck?
How is this possible?
Who is doing this?
How are they making this even what they do with the Mustang?
I love the fact that they've taken this really shit design.
It's a live axle car.
It doesn't even have independent rear suspension.
What does that mean?
That means the,
the,
the back rear tires act on one giant axle as opposed to a much more modern car.
Like the Porsche has active independent suspension.
So,
so if you go over a bump at the right,
the right absorbs it,
the left does,
and it keeps you planted to the ground better.
If you hit a bump in the shell,
but you're fucking whole asset goes up in the air.
It's just stupid design.
But they've taken that to the utmost limits.
Like they've really done the best job to harness like describing a by design.
It's like it's not,
it's not like an MMA fighter.
It's like just a huge fucking a gorilla.
It's a gorilla that's just wants to stomp on the gas and it can corner the,
especially the um,
the coops that convertibles a little flip flopping but the,
the,
the coop is pretty stiff.
They corner really good.
You can get them around a race track there,
you know,
and they have the new ones have a like a sport suspension.
But just as far as like something that's pure fun,
it fewer fund here on the highway,
it's pure fun to drive around.
It's hard to beat one of those Shelby mustangs.
They just,
the sound of it,
it's so satisfying.
It's like you're driving a goddamn sewing machine man.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's really even,
even,
even the,
when I bought,
when I bought that,
I tell you the story when I went to at least the Prius,
I go in there and I go,
I want red.
And the guy goes,
but you do it because it's,
it's,
it's Barcelona red.
And he goes,
you do you show you them on black.
He was trying to talk me.
I go,
no,
I want red place.
I want to Red Prius and please refer to it as the Red Ram.
And he's like,
what do you mean?
I go,
it's called the Red Ram and,
and it has sir your Prius Redding.
I go,
my,
what is ready?
He goes,
you're red Ram is ready.
And I made them all stand there and I drove out with my fingers like this,
curled like a Ram's horns on the hog and thing like that.
And I fucking,
I was like,
gentlemen,
thank you for your time.
And I just fucking rolled out of my Prius like this.
Like a fucking idiot,
eh,
it's called the red rim are so sexy.
Let me see it.
No one,
if you want to look up a sick one,
dude,
look up the SRT eight and I believe they're 45 or 40 looking car for their,
their top of the line one.
It's a great,
well now is this challenge or does this happen?
Independent suspension or,
yes.
Yes.
Those do.
Only the Ford Mustang.
It's a really good looking car.
That's,
that's a,
that's what fucking dove has.
Only has the racing one.
Yeah,
the RT SRT.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
I looked that up.
Look up the SRT eight challenger.
I love the fact that America is finally making cool cars again.
For the longest time all the cars looked like shit.
Like even go,
go back to like old z 28 Camaro's look so stupid.
And if you compare like the really old ones,
like the 1967 69 Camaro's,
there were amazing cars.
Even the 70 [inaudible] were works of art works of art.
Amazing when they're done up.
Right.
But then something happened and like the eighties the nineties they were just
dog shit and now they're fucking cool again.
Like I saw a Camaro ss the other day.
Some do drove by me.
I'm like,
that is a great shaped car.
Yeah.
That's the SRT eight.
That's the most expensive one,
I think.
Yeah,
it's 46 that's the special speed.
Yellow.
Maybe I'll get that one.
Fuck yeah.
Dude,
are you crazy?
That's a fun car to drive.
Rock Greg.
Fitzsimmons by the way,
just like you conflicted family man,
the whole deal.
He uh,
not that you're conflicted as a family man.
Conflicted in your ability to express your masculinity because you have
children.
He got a Prius and he wanted this so bad.
He wanted a challenge her so bad.
He was fucking,
I almost fucking bought it and he knows I hate this piece of shit.
He goes and then it doesn't get good gas mileage because I drive it like an
asshole.
He's like stomping on the gas.
Everything.
That's,
that's not me.
I like,
I like the way I,
the way I'm a retard is I'll be in the backyard with my buddy Kiran,
learning different choke holds and learning his brand at Jujitsu and boxing.
Dude,
let me tell you something that Carl make you funnier.
You get in that car,
it will make you feel like you're having a good time.
That's the car that my car,
that,
that uh,
rides car should have been my rides car was a hunk of shit.
All right.
It was a beautiful looking car and amazing construction,
but it would break down constantly.
People like someone said to me,
why did you get rid of it?
This is why I got rid of it.
I was driving on the highway going like 70 miles an hour.
Then 10 minutes later I pull into my driveway and my by wheel and suspension
detaches from the frame in my driveway,
clank cargo sideways.
So I get out,
the wheel is shoved into the fender,
the fender is dented,
and I was like,
I was just on the highway with this thing.
And like these old cars suck.
They,
they,
they handle like a rhino on roller skates,
like a drunk rhinoceros on a fucking ice skating rink.
Terrible.
They're,
they're there.
They're all designed,
fucked up.
They look amazing though.
They look incredible.
Will this car,
what these new challenges are?
It's like,
here's a car you could fucking actually drive and it actually has real breaks.
ABS brakes.
He's got a real,
you know,
traction management system and it looks the same.
It's like very similar.
You know,
you're talking about it did that,
that challenger,
it looks just like my car.
It's like,
it's so similar to my Barracuda,
although there's something about those old barracudas where you knew it was all
metal.
It was just so much more legit with all that plastic and stuff at gorgeous car.
You sold that for problem solving for some,
I made some money on it.
Yeah.
And then I just bought the Porsche.
So there's so much more fun.
But if I had to choose one,
I would take a Mustang because it's fun.
It's not the best car.
Yeah,
it does.
It's got the most refined.
The interiors made a shit plastic.
It really is about having fun.
It's about having fun.
And when I hit the gas in the car,
and I'm not even talking about going fast,
it's satisfying a blah,
blah,
blah.
My mom,
even my father,
he goes,
you guys driving?
What is this thing?
What is it?
And it Doug Davidoff all he says,
he goes,
they should call it.
They should call it instead of the Prius.
They should call it.
Um,
I won't,
I won't punch you back no matter what you do to me.
Well,
the thing is,
the reason why I say this,
he said,
I know you're not broke.
You have money.
You're a very successful guy.
You do very well.
Like you could get a car like this and it's an easy choice.
When could I can answer not a rational for the car and I want that.
That's true.
I looked at the Audi a five that's got to Twitter.
Ooh,
that's grew two foci.
Rich goes talking about what kind of car to drive.
It's not about that,
sorry.
It's about seizing passion.
It's about having fun in your flux in life and when,
if you have a car that's a fun car to drive.
If you can afford it,
only if you can afford.
If you can't afford it,
it becomes the exact opposite.
Instead of being this cool thing becomes this fucking velvet prison.
You have to drag around with you everywhere.
It's slowly sinking you and taking away your time because you had to work extra
hours.
I got to say I've had some such such nice people on Twitter say things too,
like I get such great feet like people are just so nice.
I had a guy,
I wasn't feeling very good about my one hour special because it was an hour and
a half.
I wanted to cut it down to 42 minutes to do a lot of reasons.
It doesn't matter and I was feeling a little bad.
I was like,
Oh,
I wish I could do it over again.
We talked about it and a guy tweets me,
this guy tweets me a video of his one year old daughter laughing her ass off at
my special.
I was like,
what a fucking great thing to do.
Literally like tweets it and the kid is the kid is howling and then he'd go to
me on the screen and come back to her face and the kid is fucking howling at my
jokes and like it was such a fucking great tweet.
I was like,
what a what that?
That's what I love about this.
You know this,
this whole technology age,
you can't connect a really good PT Ed brings you.
It just brings everybody together and you know,
I dunno.
It's just like minded people.
Yeah.
Like mine,
like my,
no,
you're a nice guy.
Nice people are attracted to that.
Yeah.
The,
you know,
the shows that we've been getting at.
Look,
I filmed my special in Atlanta a couple of weeks ago.
The crowds there,
they're better than any crowd that you could reasonably hope to ever get in your
life.
I believe it.
And they're there every show.
It's like the same kind of crowds at every show.
While I was in Canada,
I was in Toronto and a Yuk Yuks and I had a bunch of people that listen to your
podcast,
so they came out to see me.
Oh by the way,
I'll be in Houston June 14th 15th and 16th at the Houston Improv and then I'll
be in,
yeah.
And then I'll be at,
um,
I'm going to be at Kansas City,
Stanford and sons,
June 20th 22nd,
how that guy's classic.
Oh,
Craig correctly.
Blazer.
Awesome.
Brian Kaylin,
nobody coming in this week.
And that's a good,
that's a good Craig laiser right there.
Fried potatoes.
He's the greatest.
He was the greatest.
He introduced me to a stripper that had a tattoo of a stripper on her back and
it looked like a five year old had drawn it.
I mean it was like the worst tattoo.
It was.
She was such a pretty girl too.
And then I had this spark moment of like,
this girl needs to be rescued hardcore at that would have been [inaudible].
You could totally have taken it.
She was really pretty.
Yeah,
but this tattoo was just like this giant like warning sign that there's
something really wrong here.
I like this is complete craziness.
Like it was a,
the tattoo was so bad,
man.
Like you would have to kill the person.
They'd put that Tattoo on your body.
You would have to kill them.
There's no way you would ever,
they would not be able to pay you enough in court.
To me,
I've never known what to get as a tattoo.
I,
that was another thing.
It just wasn't me.
How bout just man coming up?
Squeeze back man.
Class man.
Class and then you see the picture.
Did you see the picture of my man class?
I'm going to Brian callen.com and I and I and they super impose my body to look
really muscular.
Show show Joe show that it's so stupid like they like make me look really
muscular.
How muscular body builder say so dumb.
Why did they do that?
Did you allow them to I wanted them to,
I want a two girls who watch him teach leg and I'm standing with fire.
It's so cheesy.
It looks like the shittiest,
like they're looking at.
Why would you do that when you can it would it be even funnier if you did it
like in your underwear?
If I wanted to,
I wanted to,
but we were like,
fuck it.
You know,
we just had that so creepy looking at who some are.
Paul Horace at some big Brazilian guy.
I just saw,
I just saw Fabrizio fair doomed down in Venice outside Jalina this restaurant
man.
What a stud.
That guy is fucking stars.
A big boy.
Yeah,
he's a big boy.
You don't realize that the fundings to Boone,
I'm a fruit thrower.
I live in the trees.
When that guy's around and he's a silver back,
I'm literally like,
yeah,
if I breach over dooms a bad motherfucker.
When comes Jitsu do you see that fight with Roy Nelson and took Roy Nelson's
back like within seconds of the fight?
Roy through a big punch missed and from Breeshia had his back.
Oh there's,
I was just,
I was watching him.
He was just sitting on the curb actually and he was,
I think it was texting and I,
and I looking at him and I said to my buddy,
I go,
I think I'm right about this.
If on the ground on the ground,
there may be one other person on the planet that could actually have,
you know,
tap that guy or maybe who knows,
maybe not.
What he's great at,
man.
His,
his fucking guard is ridiculous.
Yeah.
He's one of the hardest guys to ground and pound.
Like Ryan Parsons who's a,
he manages mayhem but I used to manage king mo and a lot of those guys who would
talk about when they would be training with Fabrice like the ground and pound
just did not work on them.
He was just so good at pretty feed on hips and his guard is so active.
I mean he's a fucking top of the food chain,
black belt and really good off his back for a giant man natural to 60 yeah.
I mean he's a big fucking guy,
you know.
No steroids.
He's just a natural to six.
So good at like his dexterity with his legs,
like moving his legs.
That's why like when fade or fell fella,
his guard,
I remember watching it and my eyes went up.
I was like really?
Like how ballsy as this guy and then all of a sudden he caught fader or in the
triangle and I'm just like,
he's fuck man.
I'm like,
this is not a regular triangle.
You are not getting out of that site.
And then when he started breaking his arm fade or finally tapped,
but watching it,
I was like,
as soon as fader I went to his garden,
my immediate instinct was like,
wow,
like that's crazy.
This guy's crazy.
Like why would you think that you could get locked up by this dude?
And then I thought about it,
I was like,
he probably never fought anybody.
Like we're doomed his whole life except for Minataro and Minataro couldn't catch
him.
So he probably felt if Minotauro couldn't catch him,
this guy can't catch him either.
But that's how good Febreeze over dooms guard is.
Probably the best heavyweight garden.
MMA next to Frank Mir is pretty God damn good too,
man.
A Frank Mir is hatches you so good at your Jitsu him.
He's so explosive too.
And he breaks shit man.
He's like,
no,
no one has had the record of breaking shit in the MMA world.
Frank Mir ways against high level guys almost broke Bach.
If Steve Mazzagatti had fucked up for one extra second because he missed the tap
and he didn't rush it and stop it quick enough.
If it had gone on for just a couple extra seconds,
that need could've blown out.
Scares me.
He broke Tim Sylvia his arm,
and then of course he broke Nogueira's arm.
I mean,
he's a big boy too.
Here's a solid to 60.
Now he's going to fight.
Uh,
Mr,
uh,
just fight for the title does something in May that's going to be a fuck.
Yeah.
That's going to be amazing.
I can't wait for that.
I really was hoping to see over him.
And of course,
yeah.
Apparently Overeem says that he took a shot by a doctor.
There was an antiinflammatory and it had testosterone in it and he didn't know
about it.
And this doctor is a,
a,
a apparently a very controversial doctor and the doctor's,
uh,
he did put on 50 pounds of muscle and listen,
it's only 50.
It's just 50.
Pick about muscle,
any thirties.
But I'm sure that was all eating a lot of steak and drinking horse.
Know what it was.
Okay.
That horse me interesting.
Have you ever seen 60 stakes stacked up?
Go to the supermarket,
go to the supermarket?
They just stop and think about six pull ups.
It's from pullups enrolling Jujitsu.
Dude,
what are you talking about?
I said,
I don't care how it got there,
just keep it on and it looks great.
He looks good.
It's God Damn Superhero.
I met him,
I met him and talked to him for a brief a little bit and when he was about his
Brock fight and he nothing but respectful
things to listen.
Men,
all the roads in the world,
there's only going to do you so much.
Good.
What?
What does Allister over him good is that he can fight his fucking ass off.
He's a scary fighter.
You can talk all the shit you want about his,
his roids,
you know,
uh,
that may or may not have taken the acquire trains hard.
He's a,
he's a very tactical filed fighter dude.
His fucking fight with Brock was,
you know,
a beat down.
That was,
that was a good convincing fight to let Brock Lesnar.
Now he does not want to have any part of any people like that.
When he kicked him in the body and you saw that shit cake to the liver.
I don't think in your thirties like Brock and in your late thirties there,
whatever it was,
you can't learn how to be at hot.
You can't strike it.
Strike no way.
Not with high level guys,
no way.
So ridiculous like a punch and he's essentially a blue belt and striking a big
strong athletic blue belt and he's taking on a 10th degree black belt,
take it on a k one grand Prix chance.
Not going to happen.
I mean Alistair Overeem as far as like decorated fighters in MMA,
he's the most decorated striker period.
He won the Grand Prix even though Badr Hari wasn't in it that year.
He still won the Goddamn Grand Prix.
He's,
that's no one's ever done that.
And then been in a high level MMA guy,
those Dutch,
he came out of those ducks schools,
which are the best camp.
And then you got the just,
you're not going to,
you're not going to be able to hang with bang with dudes who didn't doing that
for the past 10 years and now you're trying,
I mean I get so technical to Dutch,
got to give,
so you got to give Brock Lesnar a lot of credit or anybody obviously,
you know,
I have such respect for anybody who gets in that fucking octagon.
I won't,
but it's,
it's just,
it's really hard to,
I,
when I watched him lose to Cain Valasquez and I remember thinking to myself,
I said,
I,
it's really hard to meet those hands when you're,
when you're,
you can't just,
you know,
Bang with and protect yourself against a guy who's been boxing that long.
It's really hard to do.
It's very hard to do,
especially when you're coming off of fucking surgery to your bowel.
And Kane can also,
Cain is used,
he'll take a punch and punch him in the face and he keeps his eyes.
Did he have the cane fight?
Did He,
did that?
Was that fight presurgery how did it go?
Uh,
I believe that 12 inches.
No,
I think that was after,
I believe it was because he had diverticulitis.
Right,
right.
I think what happened was he had the cane fight and then,
um,
then he was supposed to have another fight,
then realized when he was supposed to fight junior dos Santos,
right?
Yeah.
And then he realized that he had to back out because of divergent died.
I think he had 12 inches of his colon removed.
God Damn.
Yeah.
The whole thing is just so crazy.
The fact that it came from,
you know,
eating meat without fiber and that it can be that dangerous.
Yeah.
That it can,
it can back up inside your body and the walls of your,
your lining of your gut get caked with excess.
What it was creates abscesses and it can actually eat its way through the wall
and the lining of your body.
It's a super duper dangerous and uh,
apparently cleared it up initially with diet and they were worried that,
you know,
you're going to need surgery,
but he cleared it up with Diet.
But then as he's training,
the real heavy,
high level training breaks your immune system down so much.
It started coming back and then they realize that this is a damaged area that's
never going to quite fully heal,
so we have to cut it out.
So then they went in there and they cut out 12 inches of his colon and then put
it all back together.
And then he took a shot to his ribs by Alice,
which is like getting hit by a safari jeep.
Okay.
That's a good way of putting it.
Yeah,
that's what it's like.
If you look at the kick to Overeem's foot is pulled towards him,
which accentuates the bone of the Shin and he's just,
Oh my God,
that's a big technique.
Giant legs slamming in your body.
I was watching,
I remember watching boss Rutten kick a bag at Beverly Hills Jujitsu.
This is like literally 12 years ago and I was watching him around house kick
this bag and I was just like the power and the force of that guy that just,
that I was just like,
I mean hit a lot of our athlete.
That was just,
I remember thinking to myself,
getting kicked in the leg or the side with that you're done.
You should see boss kicking the pads.
There's like videos of him kicking the tie pounds.
He did it very differently.
Like a lot of guys,
what they would do was they would,
uh,
they would hit the pads and or hit the bag and they would sort of like pace
themselves.
You know,
they do around,
but they wouldn't throw everything.
Full blast boss would throw every punch,
every kick 100%.
He goes,
that's what I do 100%.
He's like,
you know,
I start off,
I can only do 30 seconds.
So that's what I would do.
I do 32nd rounds going a hundred percent guys was really good at keeping things
light and you know,
you guys fighting,
like he was always good at just being playful.
I think that's how we dealt with the pressure,
you know?
Well,
he,
what his,
his strategy for training was that he would,
uh,
he would do one minute full blast as much as you can do full blast.
And then he would start adding time onto that.
You know,
he'd do a minute and 10 seconds,
maybe 20 seconds.
Next thing you know,
it's two minutes.
he can go five minutes,
like a fucking Jackhammer.
This in this book,
a extreme fear.
It's really interesting.
They do a study,
a clinical study of fear and they do and fear in different forms like fear,
uh,
combat fear,
and,
and performance fear.
Uh,
whether you're a performer or whether you're an opera singer,
you're an actor,
but mainly athletes.
And a lot of athletes get that what they call the Yips,
like in the,
in the middle of their career when they're a high level,
like all of a sudden they can't throw a baseball over a plate yet they're the
best pitcher,
you know?
And it's because what happens is people start to watch them.
Dan Jensen.
Uh,
I think that's his name,
that the most decorated speed skater of all time.
He three Olympics in a row.
He,
he just fucking just kept choking.
Really.
He kept choking until finally he just gave up.
He just,
because he got into his own head and he had to learn how to talk to him.
So finally he goes,
fuck it,
I guess I'll just skate this thousand meter.
Any,
any apologize to Wisconsin ahead of time to say,
hey guys,
I'm going to fucking,
uh,
I'm not going to win this.
Sorry.
Milwaukee or sorry,
Wisconsin.
And because he gave up and there was no pressure on him whatsoever.
He won the fucking gold.
And they talk about how a lot of athletes and a lot of people in general that
fear that
second guessing that self doubt when you're working on a high level and trying
to be get would be the best at something is something that you have to come to
terms with.
And there are psychological techniques in which to deal with it.
But it's so interesting to me that like human beings that perform on such a high
level and have so much success and get so good at something,
still have dragons to slay,
they still have fucking psychological dragons to slay.
It never ends.
You know when you really have a dragon to slay,
when you think that you don't have a drug and a slay,
that's when you really fucked.
And that's what happens to a lot of people.
They reach a certain point,
whether it's artistically,
whether it's athletically,
they reach a certain point where they feel like they've made it or there beyond
reproach.
Those are not hungry or growing anymore.
And the stagnation sets in and then mediocrity coming next.
Absolutely.
And you know,
and one of the things I always find with young people,
you know,
and I think a lot of young people listen to this,
is that they,
they,
you know,
self doubt always stops people,
but you got to realize that successful people,
all successful people have self doubt.
They'd just learn not to indulge it.
They learn to ignore it or they learned to make it how they use it.
To their advantage.
Self doubt is a human,
it's a human emotion.
It's there.
Not believing in yourself is human,
but you can learn how to deal with that.
That should never stop you from going for things.
So what if you don't believe in yourself?
So take the action anyway.
Take the first fucking stack,
right?
That's what you see with this.
And we're,
one of the things I think is so interesting because you see people with,
oh this is great,
this guy who's this therapist I was so he deals with a lot of top CEOs,
like big time fucking people who run huge corporations and they don't want
anybody knowing that they see him.
But he'll deal,
they'll see him and I'll bill out at 500 bucks an hour or whatever.
But he is,
he gets results.
And I said,
what's the over,
what's the overriding thing you have to help?
Very successful people with,
I'm talking about big time business leaders and,
and big time athlete.
And you know what he said?
He was talking about business leaders.
He goes,
um,
most of them feel like frauds.
And I went,
really?
And he goes,
yeah,
most of them feel like they don't deserve to be where they are.
They feel like they're going to be found out.
They feel generally like their frauds.
Like they just got there by fucking just to,
the gods smiled on them and now they're hearing what the fuck do they do?
And I was like,
God,
that's crazy shit.
You see these people who've run entire corporations and in their hearts they
feel like,
I'm like,
they feel like complete frauds.
That's healing.
You have to have a certain amount of humility to achieve excellence in,
in that humility,
there's gonna come a an observing eye upon you that's so critical.
You're yourself.
Observations are so much more critical than anybody else's observations to you.
If you're good at it because you know yourself more than anybody does,
you're with yourself 24 hours a day.
So a guy like that,
of course,
is going to look at himself going,
you fucking pussy.
You're freaking this whole thing.
Because really his,
his way of looking at himself is he's not really impressed with themselves.
Right.
Which is why he's done so well.
And I couldn't watch my one hour special.
I fucking hated it.
I want to know what the funk,
I know I'm much better taking it.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful with that.
You could really fuck your head up again.
Watch my old shit.
If I watch my old shit disgusted with myself.
I'm the same way.
Lapi timing and I thought I was great and then fucking you.
I'm killing the room.
The audience going quest.
Then I watched and I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
You know what's really fucked up man?
Try watching some old comedy.
I mean,
you're growing and you're getting better,
but try watching some shit from like,
you know Bob Hope from like the 1950s try watching that's dated.
Did my God,
is it dated?
It's close up.
You know,
Kinda holds up fucking Don Rickles.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
He holds up.
He's still around.
Yeah,
he's,
he's still throwing down.
He was just in Vegas in April.
Jesus Christ tweets Don Rickles.
Right?
It does get Twitter.
What's his Twitter?
He said to Bob Saget when Bob Saget was doing dirty work.
He was directing a thing.
And Bob,
he comes to set and he goes,
he goes,
he got sent to Bob Saget things.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm here to do this movie for you.
I understand you're directing the movie.
I told Mr. Martin Scorsese,
I said,
I just came from,
by the way,
I just told Martin Scorsese that you were directing a film.
The man clutched his chest.
I'm already following them.
It's done.
Rick goes,
I gotta fall.
He's got good tweets.
Rickles closes a monster.
Him on a podcast.
That'd be amazing.
Yeah.
He's uh,
he's still funny old dude.
Some guys can keep it up,
man.
You know,
in comedy it's not,
there's not that many.
There's a certain age that a lot of them hit.
Very few get to be like George Carlin.
He was really funny,
right till his death.
Well,
ever since.
It was awesome.
He also decided somewhere along the line to not just do jokes.
He was like,
I want to,
I want to talk about stuff that matters to me.
And he was so prolific.
Look at Don Rickles latest photo.
He has a picture of him and his cat and army.
Joan Rivers is almost 90.
Joan Rivers is not don Rickles.
No,
no,
no.
I mean there's the latest photo.
She looks like I can,
oh,
okay.
Here's a photo of him and her and like a green room or something like that and
she looks like a Puma.
Whoa.
Isn't that weird looking,
uh,
Pulma to,
okay.
Do you remember the time,
by the way,
still doing it.
Are you seeing their face man?
Pull up.
Pull that picture up.
75 years old.
I went into the green room once,
the Brayer Improv and uh,
I just arrived and me and Joey is smoked weed in the parking lot.
Blitzkrieg that initial rush of intoxication where you're really too hot to be
talking,
words are not going to come to you.
You're a wash in a wave of feeling and weirdness.
And I sit down,
I look up and there's some Joan Rivers reality show and I'm looking at her face.
I'm looking at her poor face.
And her face is a goddamn masks.
It's,
it's uh,
it's a,
it's not a face.
Look at that.
Come on Joan,
and she's,
and that's when she's not talking,
but when she's moving,
it's all so it's all stuffed out there with like fillers and stuff that keep
your skin from looking wrinkly there.
There's a reason they stretch your skin out.
There's a reason in the Judeo Christian mythology,
a vanity is one of the seven deadly sins,
right?
It's scary.
Vanity eats itself.
It's a snake eating its own tail.
Pull that picture up again,
Brian.
You're,
you're walking,
you're worshiping false gods.
You know,
dove and I were talking about that.
Like what happens to you when you worship false gods when you worship money,
shiny things when you worship even your own looks.
But that's crazy.
Some fucking problems.
That's Tom Riddle is actually a little better looking and a little younger
looking in some ways and she is,
oh well at least it looks natural.
If she doesn't,
doesn't offend you when you look at them.
It's like Don bears his dad.
Yeah.
Will you,
will you look at Don Rickles?
You like there's a guy,
hi.
Hi Mister.
Hi.
How are you sir?
But if you look at her,
you're like,
oh my God,
this lady is wearing a mask.
The craziest thing I've ever seen,
she looks like she has a Kabuki mask.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Gypson drawing with the knows how it's like straighten out the whole thing and
she looks like she's fighting and chief forces,
like she's like literally falling through the air.
It doesn't make her happy.
I don't know.
I mean,
does it,
she's obviously working a lot and she's happy to be working.
It does a lot of jokes about her plastic surgery.
Yeah.
But I,
I think that part,
that's one of those people that I think is driven by a whole,
they can never fill.
Right.
He,
God bless her.
I love her.
But I think that she's certainly not driven by a sense of her own inadequacy in
some way.
I mean,
I heard a documentary's amazing.
I,
yes,
I did.
I,
but,
but I mean you haven't seen it.
No,
but I want to see it.
Brian's on my list.
Yeah,
I heard it was really good,
but it just doesn't seem entertaining enough from me.
I don't know.
I'm sure it's good.
I've heard really good things,
but,
but it's,
it's,
it's like,
um,
I think that's somebody who didn't,
who never came to terms with,
with what w w who she is.
She never let go of something.
Right,
right,
right.
She's still trying to hold on it that it's,
so,
it's actually a form of madness to hold onto your youth.
Like that is,
is just mad.
It's,
it's actually crazy.
Well,
it's also,
it's another pattern.
It's a pattern.
Just like the people that stuffed the fucking plates in their lips.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a crazy pattern of plastic surgery.
There's a lot of women engage in and they start getting nips and tucks is at
her.
Yeah.
The cost.
Oh my God.
Look at her.
She was great.
She turned it on so we can hear it.
Yeah,
she was great.
All he has to be as clean and able to pick up the check.
He's a winner,
you know that.
Well,
I can call up anybody in the whole world.
You know that.
Hello?
I saw your name,
the locker room.
What?
I give you a quick call,
a girl,
a girl can't call God.
You had to wait for the phone to ring night and when you,
when you finally go on a date,
the girl has to be well dressed.
The face has to look nice.
The hair has to be in shape.
The girl has to be the one that's right and pretty intelligent up a good sport.
Howard Johnson's again,
her written here.
That's actually pretty fun right now.
30 years old.
You're not married.
You're an old man,
a man.
He's 90 years old.
He's not married.
He's a catch.
Gosh,
sorry.
Looking at me.
Yeah,
look at it.
Kind of has this Sarah Silverman type kind in the field
and bring them along.
Bring them along.
He's 98
he's dead.
Just bring them,
we'll say he's quiet.
I know what I'm speaking of back was,
my mother had two of us at home that warming as the expression goes,
movie
from a little town called Larchmont where if you're not married,
you're a girl and you're over 21 you're better off dead.
It's that simple.
You know,
and I was the last girl in Larchmont.
Do you know how that feels?
Sitting around my mother's house,
2122,
24.
Having a good time,
living,
eating candy bars and joy myself,
but single and the neighbors would come over and they'd sit to my mother.
How's Jones?
Still not married.
And My mother would say if she were alive.
You know how that hurts.
I don't want you sitting right there.
What else?
Wait
one,
my mother said,
oh,
so it's a little dated,
but still it's pretty funny.
She just,
uh,
she was excellent.
She makes sure the sex she makes you try to get her own podcast.
If he,
if,
uh,
if she was today,
yeah,
I would love to have her on a park.
No,
no,
no.
That's not what I mean.
I mean,
if you saw her back then would you like,
hey,
I want to do a podcast.
You might hear about me on the Internet and podcast.
I would,
you would try to hit it.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
I wouldn't actually,
I never tried to date a,
a common need now.
Really.
That's interesting.
I would think you would because I see you have though,
right?
I see the,
no,
never,
never.
I see the,
uh,
I love,
I mean,
look,
I love certain comics.
I like,
I love Sierra Tiana.
She's anybody who ever did it.
Ever will be lucky.
You know,
I'm,
I like,
I know a lot of fun.
I agree.
And I got a lot of friends like that,
but,
um,
oh,
but I mean a lot of like a,
I love,
uh,
Eliza slash to slash ginger.
She's my friend.
I think she's,
I just liked her.
I think that a person's funny,
but you wouldn't want to do,
I don't know about that,
that those two girls I can see,
you know,
because their friends are Monica.
I can see dating someone like that.
So I don't want to say I wouldn't date a comic,
but I,
it's marching her.
Yeah,
I'm just watching her and I kind of,
I see a lot of,
um,
uh,
need to be an overwhelming need to be loved.
And that's an end coupled with the fact that that's her first love when she's on
stage.
That's lot to compete with.
You know,
two comics is tough to make work because you're both coming together like with
your own crazy shit.
Yeah.
You know,
it works with Thomson [inaudible] and Christina Brzezinski Day at work.
Thompson were,
by the way,
is a great,
awesome guys.
He's a great,
I got to know him recently and we did this mash up comedy central Mash up
together.
He's such a fucking nice supportive dude who's genuine.
Like you'll be like,
yeah,
you fucking hilarious.
You fucking,
you know,
he's just a great,
like just one of those guys not competing with,
you know,
he's not trying to one up.
He's just genuinely happy for you.
Yeah.
He's an awesome dude.
He's a,
he's a rare gift.
That guy.
We,
we did that whole,
um,
uh,
maxim comic tour,
you know,
with me and half Ron and Charlie and we did it in every town they had.
Like a local guy would go up and do like 10 minutes.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
we did it in Phoenix and somehow or another,
um,
Sigora was on,
cause he's not really from Phoenix,
but he was in the area,
whatever.
So he went out and I was like,
Holy Shit,
this guy's funny.
And it's,
it was,
uh,
it was like,
he was so like his timing and his rhythm are so good.
I'm like,
how the fuck do I not know about this guy?
Yeah.
It's one of those weird things where I was like,
it would like kind of like kind of weird me out.
Like how come this guy's not famous?
He kind of lets the audience reach for him.
You know,
it's not,
that's a different thing.
She's controlling the space and she's gonna make you like an no matter what.
So grow is just kind of sits up there like whatever.
I'm just going to talk and he's fucking hilarious.
Got a big bit though.
It does.
Uh,
he asked me about it and I was like,
man,
really midgets need more people shitting on them.
You know?
Also,
cause I'm friends with Brad Williams,
so I don't like,
I love that guy.
He's so good.
Or a little people rather.
No Forbes.
There are midgets and not supposed to ever say midget.
Apparently you ever see that fucking out in the office,
the British one where they're like,
well they're,
they're all dwarves images.
There are sprites there or else.
It's like,
are they real?
Yes.
They're real UAT and had this debate about all the different small people.
It's fucking,
you can youtube it.
It's really,
really funny.
Have you seen those,
uh,
people that they found that live 10,000 years ago?
There really were tiny people in the island of Flores.
No.
You never seen that?
The floor,
his hobbit,
man.
Real.
My God.
How do you not know about this?
Brian?
Pull that shit up so Brian can,
uh,
look at it.
That's pretty wild.
Yeah.
They apparently they lived alongside humans as recently as 10,000 years ago.
They found their bodies,
well,
it's like pygmies.
It's like the pygmies in the Congo,
something like that.
I take it as a very small,
they were totally different.
They were a different species of humans.
They had different district,
you know,
the,
their,
their proportions were different.
I always forget that pygmies exist.
I know it's weird,
but I always forget like sometimes I'll go crazy.
Holy Shit.
Pygmies are out there.
They're fucking pygmies in the deep and the Congo,
how tall they are.
They're like four feet tall.
Wow.
I'm really muscular.
So what do you think happened?
Like there was just like,
that was the best way to be.
Like if you're going to be living,
revolve to your,
yeah,
you evolved your circumstances.
Maybe you do.
Maybe if there's not a lot of food.
The ones that survived were smaller.
Uh,
I don't know.
It's a,
it's definitely a genetic mutation mutation.
It's a genetic strain of people.
They're in their proportion.
They're not words,
they're not,
they're not midgets.
They're just turning small people.
People.
Have you ever seen the videos holdups him pygmies rushing in the Congo river.
Oh my God.
Look at how cute they are,
how tall they were.
That's a depiction of them.
But there's some better ones.
They're actual more technical ones and a dude with official over his dick.
What's up with that?
That guy.
We were there.
The ones in the far right.
Yeah.
All those.
Wow.
Fucking,
that's weird.
No,
I meant the one that was right above that bride.
Yeah.
That guy that's supposedly looked like how crazy as well.
He's a much more monkey like cheese,
but it was a type of human being.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
Apparently there was several different types of human beings.
Not just neanderthals,
not just homosapiens the real issue.
And this is the number one issue.
That other one is him as well.
Brian,
the depiction,
some pygmies pull up that fake depiction to the,
uh,
the,
the second from the left.
Yeah.
That one.
The,
the,
that's what he supposedly looked like.
If it was a really nice,
if that's a girl,
not my type,
he could be at the helm of like some British band,
you know,
some crazy Rawkus British.
Yeah.
You are correct.
You Ready to book newsy?
He,
um,
or uh,
they,
uh,
they apparently lived alongside a bunch of other ones that,
what I was going to say is that what's,
what's really difficult is that everything that dies doesn't make a fossil.
So they find fossils,
but they don't necessarily have a completely accurate record of everything that
ever lived.
And they don't know how many holes are missing.
It's really difficult to tell.
Yeah.
They found,
they just found some recent fucking thing.
Some amateur paleontologists found some recent thing that some seven foot long
thing with all these w this weird,
crazy fucking skin.
They don't know what it was.
It was,
we never seen this thing before.
Some new thing that this is the first fossil of it they found,
which is try to figure out what the fuck it is.
Sure.
They're there.
I'm sure there were a life forms.
It just didn't make it.
Do you ever buy the Titan Boa that they just recently found?
Holy fucking shit.
Huh?
How about,
uh,
a boa constrictor to each crocodiles?
Craziest thing in the world.
That's a giant serpent.
65 foot long animal drag from size.
There were dragons,
man.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's the thing that,
there's a reason why all those myths exist because things like the Komodo
Dragon,
which by the way will fucking kill you.
Okay.
How about the fucking Nile Crocodile.
Yeah.
Good luck with those 28 feet long.
Good luck with the Nile crock about whim from miles out into the ocean.
Yeah.
And I talked to a zoologist in Florida about it.
They're like,
oh,
now Kroger house will eat a tire if you throw a tire at it.
Sometimes they eat the tire.
I go,
what do you mean?
They go,
they eat everything.
I said,
everything.
He goes,
Oh No.
Comma,
they'll grab an elephant by the trunk.
There's,
there's video of it.
Have you seen the video of these dudes in the Congo?
The cuda not video,
rather.
It's a,
it was,
um,
a thing on CNN.
There were three adventures on kayaks and one of them got killed by a crocodile
off on,
they're depicting death on the Nile and it just depicting this crocodile jacking
them.
Yeah.
But here's the thing here.
Ready?
Ah,
I'm not going on the fucking,
I'm not going on the Nile,
but with the one,
it's like,
it's like the,
the thing I do,
it's like,
oh,
the Nile with I in a fucking Kayak.
Nah,
I'll go rock climbing.
How's that sound?
In the,
in the,
in the Andes or in the Rockies and I won't even do that.
Or it's like a,
it's like,
how about the guy,
the woman who got her face eaten by,
I was thinking about that as she gets,
she gets checked.
Yeah.
Hands and face eaten.
If you've got a 200 pound chimp just running around the house,
I'm not fucking common over.
Yeah,
I'll Skype with you dude.
It's a man creature with six,
seven times.
You have a body strength of a grown man with a three year old's brain.
That's a bad combination.
The
crocodile was pulling the Kayak under like a shape as it was trying to pull the
guy out of it cause it turned him over.
Oh my God.
Grabbed on.
He's still stuck in a kid.
So he's trying to hang that.
The crocodile
pulled down.
No,
no,
no.
Just went under the water and they never saw it again.
I don't want any part of that shit.
I don't want to die by,
by 20 plus feet long.
I don't want to die by biting.
It's why I don't go swimming in the fucking Santa Monica Bay cause they're great
whites all over.
They just swim around.
How's that go do,
do this.
There's a cool video of one that was taken right off the Malibu coast by a
helicopter.
But Sisay just swimming around.
I know all about the Santa Monica Bay and great whites.
I'm old hat.
I'm like saw it.
I noticed a couple of deaths and they haunt me.
One of them was a guy that was in,
they were training for a triathlon and so there was swimming in the ocean and
there was something,
there was a quite a few of them and one guy got bitten half by a great white and
that was right off of San Diego.
And then recently in Santa Barbara,
I think last year a guy got bitten half again cause he was,
when he was at,
he was a surfing and water.
He was,
he was a uh,
uh,
bodyboarding bodyboarding.
And guess what?
Well,
what they found was on nat geo that in the Santa Monica pier at any given time,
if I think it's during the fall,
there are there as many great whites there as anywhere in the world.
That's why they come to breathe.
So they're all this women among the pylons.
All right,
guess who's not going swimming in that water is Christ that scared?
I'm not going in that water.
If you had,
if you had,
if you had to choose one animal to die by,
hmm,
what would it be?
I would say a big cat.
Cause they kill you quick.
Yeah.
Cause they,
they know where their juggler.
Yeah.
You would just go out.
I go hamster.
You go right out.
It's,
I can show you know bad ass for Hampshire county.
I asked Chris definitely tie you down.
Fill the hamster up with steroids.
Ask Us man,
we're all coming up and crystal Leo goes,
ants.
I go,
dude,
that would be terrible.
I don't care.
I'm brave.
He's walked away.
I was like,
you fucking asshole.
But you hear about what ants do.
One of the things they do is they kill elephants.
They climb up the elephant's leg and they go into his ear and they start eating
the elephant from the ear,
from the inside of their ear.
This is what you know,
I have,
I have the 10 minute podcast that I do with,
well Sasso and crystal.
Yeah,
you guys want to,
it's called the 10 minute podcast.com and this is the kind of Shit we talk
about.
We pick a topic like this and we just fucking talk about it and it's 10 minutes
and if we don't finish topic,
the music sounds and we're fucking done.
The music starts and rate.
It's great.
It's been really fun.
That's a fun thing to do.
Like on a commute like listened to one.
That's,
that's,
that's why we've been doing well because we get together and dwell and I said
let's do a podcast,
but let's make it only 10 minutes everybody else and and so that's what we've
been doing and calling it 10 minute podcast,
the smart,
it's called the,
it's called the 10 minute podcast and you go to 10 minute podcast.com you can
download.
Yeah,
that's killing it.
That's a funny idea.
Yeah.
But a aunts,
uh,
I think answer the number one killer of any animal in Africa.
I believe that's true.
I don't know.
I don't know that ants,
there's more,
and I think mosquitoes,
malaria from malaria.
There's more weight per aunt on a,
or a commensurate rate as it,
as human beings.
When total body mass,
I believe it.
That's insane.
Yeah.
Think about how much bigger a person
is in a fucking aunt and they weigh,
if you added up all the weight of all the ants and all the weight of all the
people,
it would be basically the same.
Makes Sense.
Somebody said something you were saying about like if you took,
this was really in about,
uh,
they said,
it's biologist was saying if you took all the ants and you killed,
if you killed all the ants on,
on the planet,
uh,
life on earth would cease to exist in about five years as you know it,
because answer such an integral part of the ecosystem for a thousand reasons
that amazing.
He took all the humans and you got rid of them on this earth.
Uh,
life would go on.
Even just the ecosystem would be totally intact in five years.
You know,
it's just kind of an instinct,
that distinction where how much more important in some ways ants are to life on
this planet.
Then humans are because answer such an integral part of the ecosystem.
Whereas human beings are actually in a lot of ways an intrusion on,
on,
on end to constructors and all kinds of things that that requires sustainable
life.
Look what we've done to the environment as it as it stands just by living this
inexorable rise of human flesh pushing and buck and you know,
just because they won't answer,
answer like a very important part.
They provide food and aeration and all kinds of things.
I don't know what the,
you know,
I'm not a biologist,
but it was just a kind of a really interesting distinction to think that ants
and a lot of ways as a whole are way more important and actually crucial to life
on,
on planet earth.
Whereas human beings,
if you got rid of every human being life on planet earth would probably carry on
really,
really well.
You know,
it's,
it's just a,
it's kind of a humbling,
it's a humbling kind of concepts and it's killed 30 people per year.
30 people,
30 people every year.
More than weed.
Well,
bees,
I'm sure bees,
bees kill a lot more people,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
People are allergic to bees and wasps and things.
People aren't people allergic to
fire ants,
right.
Do you know how they in Australia,
you know,
they get rid of crocodiles in an area.
It's a really wild,
they'll,
they'll just kill a shitload of them in one area and then crocodiles will avoid
that area for the next five,
10 years.
Really?
They can smell the death there.
They'd even if the,
when the carcasses,
a room of when they'll shoot a bunch of crocodiles in one area and they'll keep
doing that.
I don't know for how long and then crocs will not go to that area.
How many people do you think hippos kill every year that they say kills more
people in Africa than any other animal?
Because you get in the way of a hippo in the water and you're fucking done to
you.
I don't know,
but my guess is our,
I'll give you my guest and then we're going to Google.
How many people die by snakebite and India,
which is about 20,000 from what I heard,
which is actually an inflated figure cause a lot of times when you bring your
wife in a village,
you've planned it on a snake.
Um,
having said that,
I'm going to say that the number of people in Africa killed by a hippo are up
boards of (500) 200-0900 annually.
What?
Watts?
That's the,
that's the main people was killed.
Nine 11 practicals and 900 annually
are fucked up by hippos.
They're very aggressive,
unpredictable and have no fear of humans.
People die most often when they get between a hippo deep water or between a
mother and her calf,
that's a bitch to be in the there.
They're monstrous.
They're so huge and they can run faster than you can and they'll crush you,
they bite you and they'll chase you down,
the chase you down and they'll bite your head and kill you.
The bite your whole body in half.
They by crocodiles in half.
There's so powerful.
There's a photo of a guy running in Africa.
He's running for clip down the street and the hippos chasing them and you in
that photo,
this poor fuck.
I don't know what happened to him,
but you see in that photo what?
What really is going on?
You see this monster from a movie?
It's like from that movie relic.
Yeah.
Remember the movie really quick?
Tom Sizemore.
It's crazy.
Monster comes out.
That's so primals like,
yeah,
it's so primal.
Human beings,
you know it's being eaten for a human being is actually an instinct with
children.
When when you take an infant and you go in their face,
they'll scream and cry of course,
because?
Because that's a primal fear for us.
It goes back to our genetics are 100% and hippos are about as primal as you can
get.
A big stupid giant muscle bound animal.
That's a rhino.
So Rhino son.
Oh,
it poop.
there's all,
that's hilarious.
Really funny.
Wait,
can you bring up that picture of the man running from hippo?
See if you find that.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
that's ace Ventura.
Rhino birth.
Oh,
this is so subtly.
Is this the new waistband tour or was this the old one?
Isn't there a new,
I think going to do a new ace Ventura.
I had everything.
You're doing a new dumb and dumber and they were anchored a new dumb and dumber.
Right.
What happened to him?
He kinda got bored of making movies or Jim Carrey.
Yeah,
probably just like overdose on pussy and money and money.
Wasn't he banging Jenny Mccarthy for the longest time?
That takes a lot of that.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Poor guy.
Oh my God.
She's skin is a couple of photos too.
It's not just this one.
There's another one where the thing is actually on the road in the nose.
Good luck.
Oh my God.
Look at the size of that.
The throw some marbles.
Look at the size of that thing's fucking head.
Look up images.
Yeah.
The one on the far left,
Brian.
Oh look at that.
My poor.
Fuck.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Look at the head on that thing and look at the guys just in the air.
He's running so fast.
He's in the air
that you're well,
well you know what?
Very people,
few people have ever had to run for their lives and that's that's you running
for your life.
Oh yeah.
That is legit running for your life.
The upper left one is terrifying.
That one right there.
Cause it's like he's making the turn.
Look at the eyes on it.
All.
My God,
it's so close to that poor guy.
I think he's going to fucking kill him.
Oh,
I didn't knock up on it.
The stupid fuck.
He's a game keeper.
Look,
he was like walking near it.
Oh.
And then all of a sudden the thing turned on him.
Oh Jesus.
This is some of the most frightening photos on the Internet doing that Shit.
If I see a hippo,
I'm running.
It's like when I was down,
they had,
they brought on line on set.
They brought a line.
Guess who was fucking hiding in his dressing room?
Literally.
I was like,
yeah,
you don't know how to control a lie in.
It was a male lion that they modeled the lion king after 525 pound male line,
guess what?
And all the other actors are like,
oh,
that's so neat.
Their pet,
they're like,
want to pet it?
And they're like,
oh yeah,
he's fine.
The trainer,
he's got a ponytail on a fucking,
you know,
safari outfit on.
What the fuck are you going to do?
And Mr Leone a decides,
oh,
your food.
Nothing.
Oh my God,
that's so scary.
I hid.
I had such a scary fucking animal.
Oh my God.
And the idea that it could just snap at any moment.
There's a lot of goddamn youtube videos,
dude,
I was,
you not go on Youtube.
Do you not see these animals that are being held by the trainers and also in the
just lash out.
I was in Alaska with my dad.
What does that picture?
What is this?
It's given birth to something.
Oh,
that's a hyphenate.
Eating,
eating ass out.
That's a Hyena.
Eating a Hyena.
Eating a hippos asshole.
That's what it's doing.
Have you ever seen the videos of lions eating hippos?
They just climb on them and start biting on that.
I also saw the video where the hippo bit the lion in the head and crush it.
Yeah.
How hungry the lines have to be.
They really want to eat a hippo.
Very Hung.
Tough Times,
man.
Yeah,
man,
that's not easy.
Life on the Serengeti.
People complain about Hollywood.
People complain about having a job.
Jesus Christ.
Look at,
look at what some life farms have to go through and it's amazing.
When you look at Africa,
Africa,
it's always fascinated me because that'll all the really places on earth where
there's just an overwhelming amount of dangerous monsters.
It's Africa.
I mean Africa has everything.
They have Nile crocodiles,
they have great white sharks.
They have lions,
they have hippos,
they have hyenas.
Poisonous snakes.
Austra's a kicking shit out of you.
You can head right right away.
Yeah.
They're mean.
Cuts to,
Oh fuck.
We had them in a set up of your factor.
He tried to bite you,
man.
Dude I was in,
I was in Indonesia and the rain forest,
they got wasps with like three abdomens orange for fucking,
you can see the stingers and they're just hanging out.
One got caught in my sister's hair and you know,
usually as a brave guy you killed a wasp that's in your sister's hair.
I fucking ran for the hills.
I was like my ending this new wall,
they discovered it looks like a God damn science fiction when we know they scare
the fuck out of me though.
Pull up,
pull up new giant wasp.
Discovered your,
you'll get well that's what you get in Indonesia.
I was playing with a snake with a stick and beauty.
God,
the costs a woman.
She goes uh,
at that thing by two young man,
you'll be dead in a half hour and we're six hours upstream on a boat from the
nearest hospital.
If you Google it,
Brian,
there's a crazy photo of one.
This is as big as the guys hand.
Yeah,
I didn't want any.
Nah,
no thanks.
Yeah,
that's gotten manageable.
So it bites you and it humps things you.
And if you go,
if you go back Brian,
to do an image search is about the death star.
Scorpion Star,
Scorpion.
Look at this size of this fucking thing.
Why is that in the guy's hand?
Jesus Christ.
Look,
what is he doing with that thing?
Look at this size.
That's a Japanese yellow wasp.
I think a Hornet you mean?
Yeah,
that's a Japanese yen.
If you ever seen the biggest,
yeah,
they kill bees.
They'll kill 30,000 bees.
A whole high will be coming.
They just chop a mix of them.
Six of them will buy a kill.
30,000 bees.
600 do you know how they killed them?
Yup.
They surround.
Oh,
who are you talking to?
Finish your sentences.
You mean when they served?
They cover them and flap their wings and they end the wasp dies of heat.
You might have told me that.
Well well cause cause they send a scout in,
the scale goes flying around.
He goes,
oh look a hive upbeat.
Let me drop some sent here,
be right back,
have a good day.
And they go back and then they come back with six fucking just,
it's like,
it's like all of us hanging out,
having tea and helicopter gun ships come in and just go [inaudible] you can do
like what is that?
Is that you do,
do,
do you want some more milk in the,
then you get fucking blown.
And you know what it really would be like is if we were just hanging out and
giants came into town,
just started eating us biting.
You're hiding your head off and throwing your body down and grabbing another
one.
A budding,
you're never bored with this.
Do you think they were ever giants?
I Dunno.
Is that possible?
I know I want to and I want to pet giant.
They're very loyal.
As long as you know for you to meet.
If you see like movies with giants in them,
you gotta wonder,
like,
I wonder what the biggest person ever was.
You know,
Andre the giant was 525 pounds.
And,
but I mean like giants,
I mean like 20 feet tall.
Well,
I don't think anatomically the body can really work,
but I love this conversation.
It's my favorite show.
Look at two guys.
Oh my God.
Look at this
running out the,
that's fucking scary.
Hit the jeep dude.
Or these are they really slowing down.
It made me scared.
Why are they shutting the engine off ever?
Excellent.
Good.
You know,
it's really a horrible to watch somebody.
I must be 12 with that one with it goes after the lion.
What is that?
Lower water as the water buffalo.
Did you see the one with the honey badger and a lion?
Oh yeah.
Look at these lines to bring down his hip out.
Oh,
this is so crazy.
I love this song this week
and this guy's just sitting there in a fucking truck taking video of it.
Well,
you know,
animals a lot of times won't bother you if whatever man,
one David Plan,
if I can get data plan on this thing,
ask them their show you is a video of him swimming with great whites.
That guy is a strange cat man.
He has a legit record for like holding your breath,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
He's held his breath on Oprah for 17 minutes.
How is that possible?
How talks about it on ted.com uh,
there's a,
there's a great,
he tried to do it as a trick and realized he couldn't do it and then he said the
craziest trick of all is if I really did it and you started training for it and
he'd,
he did a 50 minute lecture on ted.com about how he broke the world record
holding his breath and it's fucking amazing.
You should watch it.
But Jesus Christ,
he also caught a bullet in his mouth.
But yeah,
we a steel cylinder,
his mouth and I said,
and he had his buddy bill collusion actually shoot because bill shoots and he
just trusted bill.
He didn't move and bill shot a fucking shot.
That's funny too.
Right?
And it was mouth.
Do you think it would be,
it's always been obsessed with like,
like human suffering and going beyond the physical.
You think it would be possible for him to like swallow a oxygen container and
then have a tube coming?
He tried.
He tried,
he tried it.
He tried it.
Even when he even tried to get surgically,
tried to get a breathing tube stuff down its throat that nobody could see.
It just didn't work.
You see him,
you see him on the operating table.
Whoa.
He's pushed his button operating to what?
They opened them up.
Try to put a tube in there and they said,
go,
go to ted.com ted dot t d.com and watch David Blaine just even David Blaine and
he talks so then it's not a trick.
That's so crazy.
He actually held his breath.
He actually held his breath for 17 months and they do a lot of shit.
That wasn't a trick.
Like didn't he like stand in ice and times square for yes,
but what bothered David was that when David would spend all this money and time
doing a great trick that took him a year to perfect and it was for like
entertainment to make people feel good.
That's it.
He,
by the way,
he didn't take any,
he doesn't let anybody sponsor him.
And then he finally the target sponsor them.
And only if target gave that money to underprivileged children,
they could all have a shopping spree.
So David was actually not making any money off the shit because he wouldn't like
he turned,
I think it was coke Cole,
I want on the soft drink companies down.
They wanted to give him $1 million to do what?
To promoted to have soda.
And he said,
it's bad for you.
I'm not going to do it.
So he that he,
you know that he was offered the believe that Chris Angel did in,
in Vegas.
That was his deal.
They offered him $250 million to that fucking thing.
And he said no,
he didn't want to be a Vegas Act.
So David is a really,
David's one of those guys who just,
he doesn't tell her Vega sack though.
They're pretty bad.
They pull it off.
How do they pull it off?
He just gave,
it just shows he doesn't want,
he also doesn't want to be,
he's just,
he's just a really particular guy that way.
So what does he do?
He like puts together specials and then like what happened?
What happened was he would do,
he would do a show,
he'd spent all his time on it,
and then Fox would say,
look at all,
they'd come out with a special called behind the magic.
And they'd say,
this is how he did it.
And a lot of times they get it wrong.
That's not how he did trick.
That's not how we did it would,
they would lie,
they fucking lie.
And they'd say,
this is how he did it when David was like,
that's not how I did it.
No,
you're wrong.
But it would ruin.
It would ruin the trick.
It took all the magic out of it.
It just made him feel bad.
She's like,
fucking,
what are you doing?
It's like,
what,
why is that entertainment?
You know,
the whole point.
It's,
it's an illusion.
So that was that when he started doing these endurance feet.
Yeah.
But since I've known him since he was 17,
he was always,
always obsessed.
Yeah.
He was awesome.
He's what he was always obsessed with,
with,
um,
with Houdini and,
and David.
David,
uh,
had a tough childhood,
you know,
and,
and went through a lot and,
and I had to learn how to be,
deal with a lot of,
uh,
a lot of things that he wanted that he didn't get in.
He had that he was,
he had a,
he had to be very stoic growing up,
you know,
I don't want it to,
I don't want to betray anything cause you know,
if you get them on there,
you'll,
he can talk and say,
speak his mind.
But
David did not have an easy trial at all.
So he holds the record for holding his breath for 17 minutes.
What else did he do?
Did he do something where he stood on a block of ice for like three days or
something crazy?
He's always been obsessed by,
what do they do with,
uh,
um,
I,
I he,
he was in a block of ice for how long?
I think it was like three days or something,
but I,
that might've been a trek,
I don't know.
I would have done is the drug.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Although when I was hanging out with him,
he was walking around on a tee shirt in the middle of July,
I mean February in New York to get you used to the cold.
Really?
Yeah,
to get used to the cold.
So he was conditioning his body to deal with extreme hunger and extreme cold
like he'd goes,
he does these things.
I hope when he's here,
ask him to show you.
I don't want to give this away,
but ask him to show you his great white video.
Ask them to show you what he did with great whites.
Why would he do it?
Will blow your fucking mind.
It'll blow your mind.
You'll know nobody's really done it.
He's a weird guy,
man.
It's a weird way to make a living.
Yeah.
Holding your breath along.
He likes going to extremes.
He's an extreme dude.
He,
he's the real deal.
She does.
He have any children?
He called me today.
I just,
he just didn't leave me a message.
Does he have any children?
He does.
He has one child.
Now is this a recent thing?
I wonder if it'll change how he does these things.
Um,
he's a very loving guy,
so
I wouldn't be surprised if it did.
You could probably make that kid disappear if it doesn't work out.
Exactly.
No,
he's a really loving person
who is in case that a massive block of ice located in times square,
lightly dressed and seem to be shivering even before the blocks of ice shield
around him,
a tube supplied them with air and water while his urine was removed with another
tube.
He was encased in the box for over 63 hours.
There you go.
63 hours at 42 minutes and 15 seconds before being removed with chain saws.
The ice was transparent and resting on an elevated platform to show that it was
actually inside the ice the entire time.
Wow.
CNM confirmed that thousands of people brave the pouring rain Wednesday to catch
a glimpse of Blaine as workers cutaway the ice.
Wow.
Thousands of people out there in the rain watching this guy fucking in a blog of
ice.
He removed the ice and it was obviously days.
Wow.
Well,
this is days and the story in his date wrapped in blankets taken to the hospital
immediately because doctors field,
he might,
if he feared,
he might be going into shock.
Yeah.
Yup.
Wow.
That may or may not have been a trick.
Who knows?
But said it took a month before he was able to walk again.
Yeah.
He went through some shit.
That's so nuts.
It's got this awesome crucifix on his back like this,
this incredible rendition.
He just has always been obsessed with that sort of human suffering and that's
going beyond just that thing.
You know,
someone that someone can do something that you can't do it unless someone's
willing to do something that you can't do.
Didn't he try to do something in London though?
And they started mocking him?
Yeah.
He was in a,
he was suspended in a bridge,
in a glass case,
uh,
with nothing but for like 14 days or something.
It was in London,
right?
Yeah,
it was w when Chris Rock was like,
we've got a trick list magician.
He's living in a box with nothing that's called the project's motherfucker.
Come to my neighborhood.
I show you.
It is true to,
it's so ridiculous.
That's a dumb one.
I haven't seen Chris in her mind.
He kind of takes a long hiatus.
I think you stopped doing standup.
Really?
Yeah.
I think I read something that he started doing standup for a while.
He was doing something on Broadway too.
Maybe he's just really getting into acting or something.
Yeah,
actually it was 20 something I think.
I think some guys get to a point where they don't want to do it anymore to
create two wives.
Like anything.
When it loses its mystery,
when it loses his challenge,
I find Stanhope incredibly challenging cause I always try to keep like I'm
coming out with all the new hour.
I'm trying to reinvent myself.
It's,
it's fun.
You know?
It's one of the things.
Yeah.
I mean making people laugh.
It's like the greatest gift of all time.
And you're making yourself laugh and surprising yourself.
Yeah.
And it's like the only reason why I would ever be a drag to me is the traveling
or if my health started to fail for some reason I didn't want to get on planes
all the time that that I find traveling difficult.
The road kind of kicks my ass.
So great to be able to work around La.
There's so many clubs around La between the Improv is like the Improv,
a great club Ontario,
a great club and Irvine Greek club.
Right.
You know there's comedy and Magic Club does the Ice House in Pasadena where
we're always out.
There's so many great clubs in La that if you wanted to,
you could still keep your standup going and stay around La for awhile.
You could,
you could get get shit done.
You're right.
It's a fucking,
the Gideon the planes all the time.
It's just,
it's so unhealthy for your body.
I can't stand traveling.
I'm playing.
I fucking hate it.
It's crazy.
You know we are going to come up with better air travel.
We're still in the 50s because we can't break the speed.
You know this the sound barrier cause we'll crack windows to do with this crazy
fucking rocket rocket ship.
The earth like the earth at the you.
Yeah.
It come back down real.
The problem is that's not really what they're using it for.
They're using it to be able to fuck somebody up in New York and 12 minutes.
That's what the idea is.
It's not,
the idea is not for passengers.
The idea is to be able to fuck somebody up on the other side of the world.
It's like immediate precision.
Crazy.
It's true.
Like the drone that got the buddy,
the drone that I ran,
his supposedly now back engineered.
That to me was one of the greatest moments in my theory that life is just
theater and it's not really real.
And this is all just a work of fiction.
When Obama was on TV and said,
well we asked for it back when he's talking about the drone.
Do you remember that?
Have you seen that?
You seen him actually say that?
We asked for the drone back.
Sorry,
we were spying on you with a fucking automated Ufo that shoots missiles.
Exactly.
But dude,
I have it bad,
but on the on,
on my,
on my podcast I had this CIA paramilitary got like a real CIA guy I grew up with
and he's been in Iraq for a long time and Afghanistan and stuff and I,
I fucked the sound up and I hope probably you can fix it cause I try because I
want to,
I want to post it,
but it the dude,
Brian's done some magic.
You got to do some magic
with this guy.
I'm telling you.
I was so enlightened.
Like I follow politics.
You got to live it while he just got back from Iraq.
So He's here.
Yeah,
bring it down.
And he's not,
he's not here.
He's in a,
I can't really say where he's not.
You can't get them to come in here.
I can.
The next time he comes,
but he's really,
he's really hard to get.
He won't be on camera.
Well you don't have yeah,
camera.
Just do it again.
And the shadow,
like a shadow.
It was such a schooling for me.
It was such a schooling though for me on,
on what really goes on.
How politics really work,
how countries where we work,
how we really work.
Give me a,
for instance,
like furniture for instance.
We,
we like as far as like any kind of conspiracy theory,
he was saying,
look,
he goes,
the way shit works is everybody has different ideas and it just snowballs.
Somebody floats the idea out there that uh,
that Iran,
Iraq is a dangerous threat ultimately to US national security and they create an
intellectual argument around it.
The argument starts to win the day because a lot of other people get involved in
it.
Then there are a lot of people that disagree with it,
but what happens is then people would disagree with it,
get bullied and shut their fucking mouths.
And before you know it,
there's a lot of also private enterprise.
It's going to make a lot of money off this stuff and pretty soon before you know
it,
there's a company making fucking a hundred grand just for importing sand to Iraq
and Afghanistan,
which are deserts for the volleyball courts on the military basis.
They're making money and pretty soon the private sector is making a whole shit
load of money on this thing called the Iraq,
Afghanistan.
Oh one example.
Oh just one example.
We're bringing sand.
Yeah,
it costs a hundred in one instance for one quarter cost about a hundred grand to
bring sand and from Kansas or wherever from a sand farm in Kansas Fan,
cause you couldn't find fucking sand in Iraq for your volleyball course.
That's how the war effort works.
It becomes,
it'd be the business and everything else becomes immeshed in this massive
effort.
So before you know it,
you've got a shit load of interests working and making lots of money off this
conflict.
Now on top of that,
you have a situation like Iraq and he described our relationship with the Middle
East in Iraq as a dysfunctional relationship where it was kind of abusive,
what we were trying to do,
something we got in there and two years later we're like,
we can't cut and run now.
I asked them,
I asked him this,
I said,
do you think that Pakistan knew that fucking Osama bin Ladin was in,
was in that town of Roi,
which he had been in by the way,
six months before they caught him and I,
and he said,
fuck.
He said,
fuck yeah.
I said,
why?
He said,
I said,
why would they,
why would they keep them there?
Why would they protect him?
He said,
how many billions of dollars did we did they get from the u s government for
free for finding to find Oussama Avalon and fight the terrorism problem?
He was sitting a mile away from their west point.
You don't think they knew where he was?
You don't think that he had been protected?
That town
that he was in is the vacation spot for all of the militaries elite.
It is a beautiful fucking town.
It's high up.
Really cool.
My Buddy said it's some of the most beautiful,
majestic scenery he's ever seen.
He was all through those mountains.
Yeah,
look pretty amazing when they shoot the photos of the company.
You know what's funny about him?
He said,
he said when he was in Afghanistan,
it's a crazy conspiracy.
Then all those people over there,
the Pakistani conspiracy,
they all knew he was there and they all kept their mouth shut.
We're making billions of dollars from wins to to help us find Osama bin Ladin
and took,
contain the terrorism problem in their country.
So why in the world would you give up your golden goose,
your goose that lays the golden eggs?
Why would you give that Gustaf?
So how they spread the money around to keep everybody quiet because there was
also a bounty on Osama bin Laden's head.
Well,
$25 million.
So pair that the fuels,
but for individuals,
how was that not like something worth them stepping out?
First of all,
first of all,
we all knew the,
our military intelligence elite knew that that was probably what was going on.
We knew the signs were ceiling.
The way we found them,
you now,
we found them was through DNA.
Every time that we would,
they would take DNA samples,
they would take DNA samples from his family members.
That was one of the ways,
and they would just track those.
They,
they would,
they would try it.
They basically they would track,
um,
and then the new they had,
they knew who his courier was and they basically,
I believe it's a great story and I can't remember all the details,
but when somebody go to the hospital who was part of that family and they get a
checkup or something,
they would take a DNA sample and they would find,
and I guess they just kind of tracked wherever his DNA was,
you know,
whatever,
whoever he was related to,
they knew he had to be around relatives of some kind.
And somehow they drew a,
you know,
they had all these ingenious ways of actually finding them.
It's amazing that the Pakistanis,
if they did have,
when they were ever to keep that we're able to keep that secret for so long.
He was in the town where all the elite political and military elite vacation,
they have vacation homes there.
He was there.
What a surprise.
So amazing though.
Of course it is.
But they are amazing that they were able to step away from that $25 million
reward or whatever the hell it was.
Well,
because,
because there was such so much more money,
it was bright.
It was 25 billion individuals.
It wasn't how many do you think the individuals are making more than 25 million.
How does that 25 million spread around?
First of all,
first of all,
if you,
if you were,
if you were a guy who gave him up,
if you are a guy,
well they found him.
They found him by his DNA,
attract them to his career.
They tracked him to a show for I believe,
or is a,
I believe,
but I don't know how they found them.
Do you buy the a hundred percent of the story?
It seems kind of Wonky.
Yeah,
I do.
Because the reason he did you borrow the depth.
See?
Yeah.
I buy by all of it and the reason I buy all of it is there were so many people
in that room that watched that shit go down,
try to keep it a secret in Washington.
Try impossible.
Pretty easy to keep a secret in Pakistan.
So I guess the Pakistanis have better,
very telegenic government system,
clannish group.
Those motherfuckers aren't playing around.
Oh,
and by the way,
if you think
there's any profit and giving up where he is and you're going to give the
Americans,
think about the guy who gets the $25 million,
you think he's going to be able to hang out in Pakistan?
Would that money with that intelligence service,
the ISI and the ISS?
Or we live in Miami though.
You didn't that kind of fucking,
you had dead 25 million in Miami deer and get a nice condo.
Fucking dad.
Spend the rest on security.
Hit the clubs every night and you know,
you know what else most people believed.
Most people knew that you're not going to get that $25 million the car.
Are you going to collect it?
We're going to shoot you in the head.
Here's your money.
Stupid.
Why didn't you tell us yesterday?
Yeah,
you're not going to save that money.
Saved American lives.
Who do I go to and the,
Ah,
where's my reward?
Who would I go to with the u s government by the way?
That'd be like,
see you later.
Thanks.
What do you think about the story that he use someone as a human shield?
One of his wives or something crazy?
No,
I think what happened properly was that they,
they were afraid the first fight,
I think they probably shoot to kill orders.
But I also think,
uh,
that's all that stuff is all weighed out and way beforehand.
But I also think when a seal team like that comes in,
probably the danger and the [inaudible],
the worries that he's got,
um,
uh,
explosives on him,
he's gonna blow himself up so you don't take a chance.
So standard operating procedures put a bullet in his fucking head.
That's,
that's,
that's what I think.
They don't even try to take them though.
I don't think,
I don't think that was ever the idea.
If,
if somehow they could take him,
it would have been maybe,
you know,
but there was more profit in just getting rid of them fucking.
And what they did is they took a picture of his face.
They ran it to that facial recognition technology.
They sent,
took a picture,
sent it back to the White House they were after they put a hole in his head.
Yeah,
they were all watching it.
They were all watching it and they were watching it on a screen by Hillary
Clinton.
You can see the picture.
And then some undid some faceless CIA guys in the back.
They didn't show their face,
but,
but um,
they were watching that it was high stakes.
Obama had to go away for the weekend.
They knew where he was.
He had to go away for the weekend and he deserves credit.
He had to go away for the weekend.
And the decision was the presidents do we go in,
we know where he is.
We did.
They didn't know it was Osama bin Laden.
They knew there was a very high value target there that he knew that one of
their ace of spades or whatever they call it was there and it was probably Osama
bin Ladin and Obama had to go home alone and make the decision of whether or not
to risk American lives.
A bunch of from the bill hooks joke,
the industrialists in a smoke filled room stuck in their cigars.
Here's your agenda.
Yeah.
So the problem is the problem is that great book,
the Black Swan,
you can never control anything.
There's always,
there's always the unforeseen forces,
the photo get out.
You think they leave the photo of your guts out.
I think that it's definitely in class it's classified so it's somewhere though
still they're holding on to them so we could somehow or another get out.
Yeah,
I thought it was a bit of a mistake and they said there are going to release the
eventually.
Really?
Yeah.
I thought it was a bit of a mistake for conspiracy theorists because I mean,
because what happens is if you don't show his body and you bury him and see
cause nobody else is going to tell when they're going to release it.
Uh,
no.
When photoshops 16 comes up because it's going to be like in detectable.
That's,
that's right.
Photoshop 60 is to be the new shit.
They going to be able,
it's going to be preinstalled on your iPhone too.
That's what we're going to release it when the reality is when he met the seal
team six,
the one that did the job,
he never asked any of them who the actual shooter was.
They,
they never said it and he just shook all their hands and thank you mean Obama,
you said,
oh sorry,
I'm sorry.
Sorry about [inaudible].
You gonna shoot me.
Let me just shake all your hands a minute.
Now.
Barack Obama actually,
when he met them and congratulate them on their mission,
he never asked any of them.
He never asked who did the actual shooter was really,
and they probably wouldn't tell you.
I think it's like protocol to go to that with your grave only they know and all
that.
Yeah.
Now when the,
and then there was the other big conspiracy theory that I thought it was pretty
silly.
Well there was a crash,
you know,
a bunch of seal team,
six guys died in a helicopter and they were like,
this is a cover up because there was som in line,
wasn't even the same guys.
No,
it wasn't even the same guys.
And so people like,
but still conspiracy theories that really hard to pull off.
It's really hard to organize all that.
Well it sounds like that's not the case in Pakistan.
It's really interesting.
You know,
they had a real legitimate conspiracy going on in Pakistan for a long period of
time.
There was so much conspiracy.
They just have a very good a date they're going to control.
If you,
if you cross the,
I had the,
what is it called,
the intern mentoring.
They conspired to campus.
You can kill you.
It's amazing though that they did that for so long.
How long do you think he lived in that spot?
Uh,
well since 2011 so a long time.
And what about all those stories that he was on dialysis then?
He was gonna,
you know,
he'd probably been dead for years.
This was all horse shit.
You ever hear those?
Yeah,
I knew that I,
there was a fact that he had to,
to get dialysis,
I believe.
I believe he had an issue with his kidneys and stuff like that,
which is one of the ways they wanted to find him.
He was,
I guess was zero Stan for a while where they said they thought he was,
he actually had been wow.
And most of the high ranking military and intelligence officials would always
say he's probably somewhere in Pakistan,
but they thought he wasn't an arrow.
Odd.
They didn't expect him to be a mile away from their west point.
They didn't expect that.
They thought he was,
he was in and was zero Stan,
that law,
this region where my buddy,
who's the CIA guy I actually talk about on my podcast,
the dude was in the fucking hills with a couple of the guys and,
and,
and uh,
I said,
what happens when you get caught?
He goes,
you don't get caught dude.
And I said,
what do you mean?
He goes,
you're not letting them catch you.
I said,
so what is the alternative?
Because you've got enough ammo,
you shoot it and then you say one bullet for yourself.
And I went,
I went,
really?
He goes,
you don't want to get caught by those guys.
The you,
you don't want to get caught by Afghanis are those push tunes that will fuck you
up.
You shoot yourself.
I was like,
that's why my buddy lives.
And I was like,
that's living on the edge.
She's,
he's a real,
but he's always been the baddest dude.
I know.
He's always been the baddest motherfucker on the piano.
He's such a bad ass and you would never know it.
He's the guy,
he's to fight for guys just open up on you.
Like,
you know,
he would fight for guys,
no problem.
Why would he do that for marines?
Take his jacket off.
I want to fight these guys.
Fly reason why.
No,
you know these fucking guys are chasing them with my buddy,
my buddy and he,
my buddy told me this story.
He didn't tell me the story.
My buddy,
my buddy said he stopped and they were,
they were running down an alley for guys.
And he goes,
I'm going to fight him.
And my buddy goes,
what?
And he goes,
I'm going to fight.
I want to see if I can find it.
My buddy goes,
don't do that dude,
please don't do that.
And he goes,
no,
I'm going to do it.
And he took his jacket off and he fought them.
Just fucking
started swinging and kicking.
But he was a really,
really,
really good fighter and could hit like a heavyweight and uh,
and fucking did just fine.
And you know,
he does,
but his buddy had to sit there and fight now.
But those guys were like,
why am I getting hit like this?
Why am I getting fucking kicked and hit and we'll kick in my head and it was
pretty wild.
There's a lot of people out there that have lived some pretty fucking intense
life.
He loved danger.
He was really good in the violence space.
This is the way he told me.
It's the only time he fell alive.
It's funny when we talk about like David Blaine like his,
this desire to try to push the envelope of what a human being can do with
holding his breath or with ice or we had talked about on the podcast for this
David Goggins guy who was one of those iron man guys ever seen him before.
He's got a bunch of videos online,
but he engages in 48 hour races where they run for 48 hours straight on a track
and people monitor human beings.
I'll track.
Human beings are the best long distance animals on the planet.
Yeah,
we killed,
that's how we keep persistence.
Hunting would kill certain animals in Africa,
but you know,
these,
these people that are trying to push the limits,
you know,
and they,
it takes a long time to build up to it.
I'll go.
An interesting thing that happens with a lot of young MMA fighters is they kind
of underestimate the kind of conditioning that's required to be a five round
fighter and how intense and how much is involved and how long the process is to
build your body into a body that can withstand work for 25 minutes.
You know,
in an arts that's an e on anybody's wrestled,
which I did,
six minutes is a fucking eternity.
25 minutes is the craziest thing I've ever heard of my Saturday.
It's the,
the amount of exertion that your body has to go through.
It takes a long fucking time to build up to it.
And a lot of guys suffer from overtraining in the beginning of their career
because their body simply not conditioned to be able to handle that kind of work
rate.
It's just not,
you know,
there's,
especially when it comes to like a lot of kickboxers who'd go into MMA,
they have no idea how difficult the wrestling aspect of it and how much more it
takes out of you and they almost always gas when the fights turn into wrestling
matches initially,
like a lot of the striking base guys,
they have the hardest time developing that wrestling endurance.
It's so,
so much tension.
It shuts full exertion,
you know?
I mean people really don't respect MMA fighters enough as far as the amount of
discipline that it's required to,
to,
to be in condition,
to fight a full five round MMA fight or even a three round fight.
My,
my experience was with that was I was on a date in my house.
I had married,
I had my two pit bulls piggy,
I'm sorry,
Peggy was my pit bull and Stella was my German shepherd,
my police,
German shepherd,
my,
my fucking working class,
German German shepherd,
a fucking wolf.
And they got,
they locked onto each other and I was,
I wasn't that,
I didn't want them,
it was wasn't that I didn't want him to kill each other.
I was just seeing vet bills.
I was just seeing thousand dollars here because as they were ripping into each
other and I,
and I was on my front lawn wrestling with these two dogs and a choking one out.
Then the other one would cut fall and then the other one
would get ahold of the other one.
And I have to choke that one out and went back and forth as I'm trying to break
them up.
Like I kept choking each one,
each fucking dog out and I was so furious.
And when my buddy Bob came home and,
and,
and jumped off the,
the,
my jumped into the yard and,
and fucking and jumped on both dogs and put his knees on both their heads and
just held him there and,
and,
and finally that echo from exhaustion.
I was so exhausted.
I don't even know how long I was there.
I was like 15 minutes fighting with two dogs.
I remember crawling up in the corner in my yard,
I crawled up in a corner and I was like breathing like I've never like from
wrestling all that shit,
there's no comparison.
Cause I was literally,
I was fighting for my life and I was going and imagine and I was on a date.
I didn't even,
I didn't even really have time to look cool.
I was going and my hands,
I didn't realize my own my own hands for fucking a week after that I had trouble
closing and opening my hands cause I had,
I had,
I like torn all the muscles in my hands from trying to pull them apart.
Imagine you weren't even engaged in combat with them.
You were trying to stop,
stop the,
kill you.
Well that's,
that's like this book,
extreme fear where the woman gets in a fight with a mountain lion.
This female mountain lion stalked her and tried to kill her and she ended up
just fucking,
she took this,
uh,
like,
some kind of a,
like a knife for like something and a spike and was sticking in its eye and she
just turned,
she,
her fear turned a fury and she started fighting back.
But you know,
she was fucking fucked up.
When you get into a fight with a real animal.
Oh yeah.
Especially with mountain line.
You're done.
You're so,
we're so fleshy.
Your food,
they're predators.
Your food.
Our skin's made a toilet paper.
That's where there's,
it was made of leather.
That's right.
Like deer have leather.
Deerskin that's exactly the right shoes out of it,
man.
The skin is so tough.
You don't make,
nobody makes skin at a human rights.
You know,
Schuman,
shoes.
No,
they,
they take down,
they take down elk.
Go try to bite it.
But yeah,
try biting you and elk to down by the,
the grab it with their claws and they bite it with their face.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
Good luck.
Good luck measuring up with you'd face.
That's what I say about great whites.
I go try biting a seal,
the death,
it'll bite it on a flipper and level five.
I mean I can get the fuck off me
kid a little.
That's my argument was up to those people that are,
when I lived in Colorado when I was saying you should kill these fucking things,
and people were so angry at me after one of them killed my dog.
That really did happen.
Like I was telling him like,
why do you allow mountain lions stick around?
Well,
you know,
hey,
they're a part of nature and you know they're,
they're here too.
I go,
if there was a guy running around that could kill a deer with his face and
occasionally he would eat dogs when you want him in jail.
Yeah.
Well this is way scarier than a guy that could do it.
You stupid.
Fuck,
this is an animal and they fucking,
they make a bunch of other animals just like it.
And then they live in the woods and they eat dogs and people to whatever there.
Yeah,
they've had I think six to eight a mountain lion attacks.
But I love mountain lines.
It doesn't mean you want to kill mountain lions.
You've just got to be aware that where they are,
you know,
kill him.
Light him up.
Fuck those mountain lions.
Kill an Apex Predator.
Gid Rid of him.
Get him out.
The joke I did,
I did it about I like
I'm pro mountain mine.
You bastard.
Whoa saying was like the argument that I got in with a guy and this is actually
in my act,
but it is true.
The Guy told me that we needed them to keep the deer population down.
And I said,
do you know the deer not bulletproof and they're made out of food.
Stupid.
Fuck.
It was a real conversation.
I was like,
this is the dumbest conversation ever.
You need.
Well wild Munsters running through the woods to eat up all the extra food and
interesting thing.
It's an interesting question cause I,
I personally think all animals like that,
like tigers and lions should all be preserved because they,
so just for the sake of how beautiful they are,
I believe everything in other continents,
just not where I live.
Nothing that can swim across the ocean and Jack You,
I'm not even big on leopards who like live like Mexico and they're making it
across the border.
The Jaguars,
Jaguars.
Jaguars are way more dangerous than a leopard.
They're much bigger because they are not afraid of people.
They will kill him.
Bebo they you don't have a chance against the Jag.
Not a chance.
It's a in the Amazon when people take Iowasca you know that crazy jungle
intoxicant one of the things,
the visions that they see is jaguars like a constant like bunch of chat guars
like watching them and Jaguars communicating with them.
My Buddy told me a story of this guy who is Cia guy told me a story that in the
Congo or somewhere in Africa,
this dude decided he wanted,
he was like a,
like an embassy,
you know,
guy,
we're going to just want to be part of the culture.
And he went to this African tribe and he drank some tea that they gave him and
all of a sudden he fucking starts hallucinating and he runs off with his cell
phone naked and he decided that they were trying to eat him,
which I don't know,
but he goes,
these people are trying to eat me.
And they had to send this huge search in part like a rescue team out to the
middle of the fucking Congo and track him down with his cell phone and find
them.
It was this massive operation.
They found him.
He was eating the shreds by bugs,
caught up by thorns,
all fucked up.
I had to go to the hospital.
He was there like three days,
like running through the forest away from what he thought.
Were people trying to eat them because of this fucking hallucinogenic tea.
I mean,
well they were probably like really sweet African people,
you know,
who had degrees and sure maybe they were trying to eat them or maybe they were
trying to eat him though.
Who the fuck knows,
came to grips with the reality that a lot of people eating,
people in parts of the world actually ever meet like Africans in this country.
They all have like six degrees.
Like Nigerians find me a judge,
jury and doesn't have at least his masters.
I'm going every single time that he goes.
Well I,
I have my,
my degree in,
uh,
in all kinds of things in a mechanical engineering and my doctorate in,
it's like a fucking,
I imagine is the whole world was like Africa.
Africa is actually,
I talked to my buddy about Africa who was,
is the CIA,
you know,
the guy,
I shouldn't even say CIA,
let's just say he's whatever.
And he said,
um,
he said,
uh,
he's really optimistic about Africa and not optimistic about the Middle East at
all.
Really.
So optimistic about the progress of Liberia.
Not about guest very much because Africa actually in a lot of ways has,
has come to terms to these terrible wars with a lot of their,
their,
their civil strife there of tribal strife.
It,
what's the band,
their mineral issues.
You know that a lot of these
wars in Liberia and Sierra Leone was,
was,
was fighting over resources,
diamonds,
the diamond mines,
uh,
um,
and the material in the Congo,
the material that goes into cell phones,
that,
that's really where these warring factions,
um,
fight over it.
But also they're solving a lot of their political problems.
I mean a lot of these,
a lot of African states where we're dictatorships just like in South America.
So he thinks that they can be worked out,
but they are being worked out.
Why not the Middle East but the Middle East mainly because the Middle East.
Is there a couple of reasons.
One is,
and one of the things he brought up with very interesting,
he said the notion that you can separate Islam from democracy as in you can,
one of the things the tenants that we have is the separation of church and
state.
The Koran is a blueprint for how to run a society.
Even how to manage your banking laws and things.
It's very difficult to separate Islam from an Islam Islam from state run affairs
traditionally in the Middle East.
The only way you did do that was by imposing an iron fist,
the way Saddam Hussein did,
the way Eh,
countless Arab dictators did.
Um,
that's one of the issues.
But the other issue is the Sunni Shia rivalries that,
that are constantly,
you know,
playing out now in not just in Bahrain but in Syria and,
and a lot of different parts and certainly in Iraq.
And the only way to control that is one side's got to have more guns in the
other side.
And I have a different point of view by the way,
but which is that I think commerce ultimately when commerce comes to these
countries in which it is,
I think people are going to have a lot more to lose.
I think economic,
economic prosperity,
we economic prosperity and quality and technology,
I hope.
I hope for the Middle East is going to make it a better place to live for the
people there.
But,
um,
but I do think that if you look at,
for example,
Egypt now,
Egypt has,
if you look at who's running for election,
they have essentially hardline Islamicists who are going to impose,
you know,
or the,
the,
the worry is that they're going to impose real well Shiria or something like
that.
That's certainly not very democratic.
Uh,
so,
you know,
but did you want to go back to them a barks,
rain?
How did those dictators,
how's that going to be stopped?
You think it's only money that's gonna be able to stop?
I think,
I think what happens with all countries,
it's,
look,
you know,
how to stop at time.
What happens is take a look at what happened in Europe.
Take a look at what happened when Central America,
these are democracies,
imperfect democracies,
but there's certainly not military dictatorships.
You think there's a real shy,
even in China,
China is learning that basically democracy is an inevitable,
inevitable thing that they have to come to terms with.
And when I say democracy,
I mean a government that listens to its people.
It.
How do you keep,
uh,
people in,
in ignorance?
How do you keep people ignorant when they have access to the Internet?
You don't.
Human beings now have access to real information and the truth of what's really
going on,
and more importantly,
they can see how other countries are living.
It's very difficult to control and have power over a people when they know the
truth.
And one of the most unique things about what's going on in the Middle East today
is that these uprisings are uprisings that are happening organically from within
the population.
They are not being manipulated by an p an imperialistic power.
They're not being manipulated by,
by another Arab country.
These are homegrown,
grassroots rebellions that are very difficult to,
to ignore.
And the people that are doing it are young people who just want a better life.
And I can tell you right now that if these theocracies,
if they vote in these,
these,
these Islamicists and they don't see results,
you're gonna see more rebellion.
And so I think that that whether or not these countries are Islamised,
they're going to have to listen to their populations and they're going to have
to be,
they're going to have to respect individual freedoms.
That's my belief.
That's my hope anyway.
I may be naive.
Yeah.
Wow.
Good Hope.
I hope so.
[inaudible] a beautiful idea that eventually we're all going to come to some
sort of a utopian sense system of government that we're all going to accept
because it's all going to be the will of the people.
It's just the will of the people in this country is slowly being choked and the,
the,
all the,
the provisions provided by the constitution are slowly being choked out.
I agree with you in government.
That's scary.
The biggest,
the biggest problem is I think a lot of government governments,
and I'm talking about municipal governments,
state governments,
well,
they're becoming more concerned with their own,
with their own employees and the people that they're trying to serve.
They want to keep jobs going,
so they want to keep laws in place.
If there's no one to arrest for anything,
then there's no need for that job.
What's happening to the people and the DEA.
A lot of people in drug enforcement that are actively lobbying to keep certain
really nonlethal non-dangerous drugs and keep them illegal because they want to
have people to rest for things.
There's only of the problem with private prisons and you have the PR,
there's so many different fucking
problems.
Well,
well it's anytime somebody has a vested interest in something,
they're going to try to protect that interest and regardless of whether they're
a good person or a bad person,
we have a vested interest in marijuana.
That's right.
We're trying to protect the marijuana.
I um,
I'm going to have to run soon.
I have to close this thing down.
Let's shut it off.
Once again,
my dear friend,
thanks for having me.
D driven sort of a conversation until all sorts of bizarre subjects.
I love it,
man.
Man,
I never,
I never have a bad time.
It's always enlightening.
Make sure you check out Brian [inaudible].
Brian Callahan has,
what do you call the bank account show?
Perfect name.
Couldn't be any better.
I'm feel pretentious with the Joe Rogan experience.
Got Some great guests.
My Sam Brown,
my buddy's dying of cancer.
I mean not dying.
I don't want to say it,
but he's fucking hilarious.
He's,
he's got pancreatic cancer and he's,
he's hilarious.
And I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do another one.
I
got a,
I got a fucking,
um,
uh,
Anthony Tan back cause I'm gonna post soon,
which was a great podcast.
The Braga and Catelynn show that music for your Brian Cowen shown.
Not yet.
I don't,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to start coming into the studio and,
oh,
go to the 10 minute podcast.
Yes.
10 minute podcasts.
It's funny shit,
Chris Delea and will Sasso Sasso.
Very funny motherfucker.
That's the end of this dirty ride.
Ladies and gentlemen.
That's probably the end for this week too.
We were going to do something with a certain controversial person tomorrow,
but you know what,
it's just why,
why,
why even bother?
Yeah.
We just,
uh,
sorry.
There's too much crazy going on in this world.
The small one.
I don't feel like jumping into a river of any more crazy.
Right.
Um,
that's it.
Thanks to the fleshlight for tuning into this,
sponsoring this excursion this weekend here in New York,
but it's already sold out,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
We're in to me and Dunkin and yeah,
for people who come to the show,
don't know who's on it.
It's me and Dunkin and Joey Diaz and it is the day before there was a UFC,
uh,
in,
New Jersey and we're at the grand ballroom and,
uh,
the Manhattan Center.
She'll be a lot of fun.
I haven't been in New York about,
it's probably been about like a year.
Good Times.
You dirty freaks.
Um,
thank you again to our sponsors.
The fleshlight.
Please go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight entering the Code Day.
Rogan,
save yourself 15% off.
Thank you again to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune and new mood.
All of them.
All of your questions can be answered on,
on at.com.
O n n I.
T.
And for people that are asking about the kettlebells,
it's everything's going to be handled really soon.
It's just a shipping issue we're trying to work out.
So we have to move everything into a different location.
So within the next couple of weeks it'll be all for sale and we'll let you know
what's going down a lot.
A lot of cool shit's coming up.
Good protein part of,
uh,
hemp protein powder and a bunch of other stuff.
So that's it.
Um,
we will see you all Monday.
Kevin Smith wants to do next week.
I think I'm going to do his though.
I think I have to do his,
I think that's how it works.
I think we,
you know,
cause he did ours last saw.
Yeah,
I got to do this.
So I'll do that next week and we're going to try to get dice next week to Holla.
Yeah,
we should have a bunch of fun ones coming up soon.
So,
uh,
that's it.
Uh,
sorry about the big bomber yesterday,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Sometimes things get,
things go wrong.
We don't,
we don't mean that much more fun to have a cow,
a calm and cool and interesting and the situation's been fixed if you day listen
to it.
Yeah.
Ice House is now paying.
I don't have anything to do with it.
Yes.
So there's the [inaudible].
There you go.
Sarah Tiana and make sure you tweet me down and I'll retweet that and uh,
we'll probably do one next week as well cause I'm going to be back in town.
So uh,
thank you to everybody that tunes in and thanks to all your messages,
even your country.
One's about the little spat yesterday.
I see a lot of you have opinions and it's nice that you care.
Just try to try to be nice,
try to be friendly,
try not to be so twatty there's just too much twatty behavior in this world.
So next week,
which is like the 11th,
we'll probably have another one at the ice house.
So if you're planning on flying in from,
where'd the people flying from?
We have people hand it out.
They were going on a comedy tour and now is a that,
that,
that squad show is the last show of the tour.
He just wrote me just to thank me because I,
I mean that's the guy with the green shirt.
Yeah.
And uh,
so we,
I gave them a tour of the studio,
which I usually don't do,
but what's cool about guy?
Yeah,
great guy.
What's cool about that guy too is that he said that,
uh,
he ran into me at south comedy hole a year ago and I told him to do comedy.
So he went and did comedy and now he's a comedian.
He was thinking about doing it and I was like,
go fucking do it man.
And so he listened to me and now he's actually comedian.
He's touring all over the country.
Wow.
Crazy.
Isn't it amazing how fast you could change fucking life?
Come on.
Little inspiration.
You Pussy fear getting away now you got to get rid of that fucking Prius and get
a man's car.
I'm going to do it.
We figured out that shirt for this podcast.
I have to get a charger charger.
Is that what I had to gap challenger.
A champion charge is not bad.
Two charges got four doors pretty goddamn fast.
Excellent Interior.
The SRTA challenger.
Very nice car.
So is the charger both very good and they're fucking American.
He can feel good about it.
Pull up to your dad's house and the God damned American car.
He'll be so happy for you.
I'm writing.
Would he be son?
Come around and get off those Japanese gay cars.
Roll like the penis.
All right.
He's dirty bitches.
We'll see you soon.
And thanks for everything.
Bye Bye.
See you guys in New York hollow.
Hm.